[Music]
is selling out a thing anymore
that's a you know what after rat
tattooey i think
david cross was in the chipmunks
that's it that's the nail in the coffin
is a good movie though it's great it's
pixar you can't go wrong that's really
fascinating i've never done an animated
well i feel like you would do it i would
love to do an animal oh my god
i could have voiced the pigeon i feel
like
[Laughter]
i feel like you could do a pixar movie i
had my first animated um thing what you
do is you go to the table read and they
write it kind of like with your
mannerisms in mind the first one it was
like back in the day when like tj miller
got every job yes you know what i mean
and it was like he's got a great voice
i mean
[Laughter]
so he's there he's playing every role
probably and then uh i was a sex it was
like the airplanes like spin-off and i
was like a like a a [ __ ] jet
who was always like getting to like
causing problems she's not a virgin
totally come up and see me sometimes
yeah complain right and i didn't i was
so grateful to have a job in that space
because i'm not known for having a voice
that's like soothing to like people
don't think of like my voice as
something they want to like isolate and
listen to and so uh
and then later the guy that ran the
studio was fired for sexual harassment
and all this crazy stuff and they were
like that was totally inappropriate he
should have been the voice yeah
like all the executives were like we're
so sorry like that was very creepy and i
was like i didn't i i didn't think so
yeah
wow was that pixar i don't remember it
was what that one of the yeah the movie
just went away you didn't get to do it
and a lot of animated movies like earth
movies in general you know you're like
attached
new writers and it takes forever and i
don't know if it ever happens yeah they
book a lot of comedians for these like
pets and all these you know uh
spider-man and mullany in it but once
they go back that was another good movie
too that was a great movie spider-verse
the new one i haven't seen it yet no the
one with the cartoon oh yeah incredible
yeah what's the last movie you saw in a
theater 1918.
that year
no well that's 17 19 17. yeah but then
no i saw joe list and louie's movie i
saw that at the beacon because they did
but other than that 1917 is the last
movie so that's crazy i want to see top
gun i'm going tomorrow what's the last
one austin i'm gonna go yeah that's fun
that's my last movie top gun top gun and
you know it's cheese it's americana but
by the end you're like
you got like a maga hat on you're all in
yeah running into schools is good
yeah stopping abortions yeah that's
great
you really get like riled up in that one
yeah it's fun i feel like i i feel like
um i don't go see movies in theaters i
do feel like i see documentaries of my
new thing is that
i'll watch a documentary and talk about
it as if i've
have a phd right yeah it's also
documentaries the subject matter isn't
even like cerebral anymore no it's like
discrimination and abercrombie and fitch
and i'm like you guys i saw this
documentary last night right right which
by the way like we've all seen those
stories we could have assumed yeah we
knew that they were sure
right that's what we liked about it was
two man boys outside shirtless what more
do you need they're like they only had
white employees we're like yeah
you can't get away with the [ __ ] in
thailand are you kidding me
do you remember that abercrombie and
fitch used to make t-shirts with like
very racist no i don't really like as
soon as i saw them i remembered right
away like i feel like i definitely
what bought one of those in a buffalo
exchange for a couple bucks wait a
minute what are we drinking today by the
way oh and let's let's keep on that stay
on eastern i'm making an eastern
standard right now
i've never heard of this drink whitney
requested it but it's with tequila which
is unusual because that's normal it's
normally a gin drink actually oh i
didn't know that because the eastern
standard is actually from soho house
like they made it popular oh really i am
the worst person ever oh
no that's a good idea when i try to not
be cool i'm looking at hollywood [ __ ]
it was highly rated when i looked it up
it had no i thought okay this is how
much of a basic [ __ ] ignorant [ __ ] i
am i am the worst i hate myself so i
went um to a dinner with someone once
and at the sunset tower hotel an agent
who ordered an eastern standard and i
was like oh this must be like an
old-timey drink from like the 1850s like
in the apoca ferry or something and
it's the official like drink of the soho
house
which is based on uh
i know like i talk i like think that i'm
like classy and like know some [ __ ] yeah
so it's actually like it derives from a
gin gimlet the original one gimlet
that's what i thought it was just like
gin and the lime cordial but this is a
tequila version we just wore these we
just wore these shirts to the dave
matthews band concert
hike your skirt up a little more
crushing to me hey little girl show your
world to me oh yeah good innuendo
yeah
pretty subtle i never won brothers yeah
that's a tough not great rickshaw
although that podcast would do great if
bobby and his brother were just doing
podcasts together yeah if you don't want
to be right
[Laughter]
like this stuff i
yeah so there was a huge class action
lawsuit wow that asian employees sued
and um a bunch of them like they would
hire
diverse employees but they would never
call them in for shifts so they're like
we don't we don't have any shifts for
you damn wow so they could and then they
they called in um like an investigator
what would you call that like a
forensics like
someone that comes in to like like a
secret shopper company uh-huh
and like
right and the guy just went everyone
black here called in sick today this is
crazy yeah right what are the odds do
you know about sickle cell anemia
no
the guy was like i couldn't help them
like there was i there was i couldn't
even wow like i didn't take the job like
they offered me all the it was like they
were too far gone
oh and the photographer of all these
[ __ ] the boys what yes wow what a wrap
no it was not her brits it was another
guy
close her brits is a great name though
for for some of her [ __ ] boys yeah
that's so because your last name is like
a children's cracker oh yeah right
that's true it's like it sounds like a
kiddo yes that does sound fancy it is
fun funny that ritz
bruce weber yeah that's the guy and the
guys
tell stories they're all like working in
saloons now and like you seen your vlogs
as like waiters well if you're gonna
[ __ ] boys those abercrombie dudes were
hunks he's like what would hitler want
to [ __ ]
that is some top shelf boy [ __ ] right
yeah totally it's very like nazi porn
yeah yeah that's what abercrombie and
fitch was they definitely did not have
jewish models for sure
trying to run a business
nazis were hot remember that nazi in
indiana jones
she was gorgeous
the blonde
i feel like if kim basinger was in like
in
earth not earth girls are easy my
stepmother uh was the alien alien have
you seen that movie recently
it's incredible she's hot she's not only
hot she's so funny really like you know
how hard it is for me to say that it's
funny yeah
yeah
kim basinger that's something
oh yeah no no that's the nazi she was
the mom in eight mile like that was kind
of yeah but that way confidential won
the hands down the most beautiful woman
to ever live you think so
what do you think i would say michelle
pfeiffer i like rachel ray
rachel ray yeah i'm a big honey boo boo
guy by the way rachel ray have you been
around her no she's really sexy i could
see that she's sexy and that like this
perky because she's gorgeous like her
she is incredible
no no
i'm saying she's she's got this like
magnetism and this charisma she seems
like she does anal like she has a fun
positive vibe about her hopefully she
didn't make turkey chili that day
[Laughter]
impossible turkey chili
no no i feel like a lot of west coast
people are ve i feel like it starts over
there and then it works its way i always
mean healthy that's true that's true i
think that's the thing about veganism
all that like seitan and tofu
sodium it's just trash can you eat ass
if you're vegan that's an honest
question
if the person's ass you're eating is
vegan ah good point good point that'll
right yeah you're right it's not always
healthy but you do hear about like
reduced inflammation and stuff like some
pro athletes go vegan yeah they just add
like three years to their career
okay you're not wrong because most of it
breaks down into sugar which is right is
this nine and a half weeks no this is uh
comedy movie oh that's dan aykroyd yeah
my dad looked exactly like that he used
to sign autographs as well
i thought it was dan akroyd oh she was
the most gorgeous ever yeah
this movie is
shocking wow the 80s huh she's an alien
that comes down
and it's wild cause she's kind of like a
child in a way because she's this young
girl like yeah she's like this baby
alien in a big woman's body
like remember big yeah i was trying to
make a little bit of a play of like
he was technically 13 even though he was
in a 30 year old man's body
perkins was 30. so that was creepy it's
like
[ __ ] nerds yes it's a [ __ ] comedy
you know this is an argument i'm trying
to make you did texting like premises
like that i'm like working on for jokes
before we get into that let's coach real
quick
and then get into it to whitney's
relapse
i love you yeah i do think my rock
bottom was last time you were on my
podcast that was a wild adventure that
was fun i saw pictures of that five-hour
excursion i did not know that you guys
would have to drink the drink i picked
oh no that's part of the fun i ate it
okay i don't know it's delicious i i
don't think i like the whole drink in
the same drink thing i don't like the
ordering different i like being on the
same yeah
i like that too because there is
something um
that really
drives a wedge between us when you order
something else
because there's a judgment i'm like oh
can i have a whiskey sour and you're
like i'll have a jack and coke and it's
like that's not the night i was having
right oh we're getting a divorce
i thought we were celebrating this is
what it's like to date any woman right
now
uh reading but nobody at least then
though it's still whiskey i mean doing
like someone's doing like mezcal another
person's doing wine i'm like we're all
over the place
i like i like mark and i like doing the
same drink that's like yeah that's nice
but the ultimate bad one is when you're
drinking and they're like i'll have a
sell sir and you're like you got a drink
with me i can't sit here and drink alone
it's the worst feeling i could have
stayed at home and done that yeah or if
you get ice cream and they get a salad
you're like this sucks yeah you've got
to be breaking when you're being bad and
they're being good that's the way to put
it it is annoying i would say if you're
being good for whatever reason you need
just don't come just don't come out
because i i just feel judged i can't
come when i'm being good
i feel attacked
how do you feel about
people blaming
their bad choices on the specific
alcohol they drank oh that's fun you
know when people like i can't have
whiskey i cannot have whiskey i just i
call my exes and you're like that's
no gin
racist
i used to have humphrey bogart as my
screen lock screen thing because it'd be
like bogey wouldn't call an x
interesting be like bogey wow mine was
my ex
don't call her mine was actually your ex
there was a minute where
blackberries
if you did bbm
yes the person could see how you
programmed them in
what
blackberry messenger you don't remember
oh i never had them
because i remember it like it was
yesterday i remember the font yeah it
was blackberry it was the one with the
roller on this yeah i remember the
roller the golden teeth so if i i
learned to work a [ __ ]
by the way i do feel like guys that age
have like like a tunnel um but uh there
was a time where they could see how you
programmed them and there was one time
this guy that i was like do not ever
answer like he was just like a more ass
of just like nightmare he would just
like suck you in like a vampire and um
that doesn't have the roller though get
the roller get the roll i literally
wrote like
loser
slash
do not pick up
oh
like i'm 22 and i'm like this is when he
calls i'm going to see that
we're going to talk about shots
come on
i mean i've look i would never call him
i don't want to burst his cauliflower
here
there's your roller all right whoa so
yeah there was one on the side also i
think that's right like a scroll but i
remember like i feel like if people knew
how i saved them they would not be if
they were like you saved me as older
woman tampa you know like yeah
like literally like um uh cincinnati
uh honey allergy yeah peanut allergy
yeah like redhead tampa that's exactly
right i have rachel ray anala
um so do you think that it's true that a
different side of people like
comes out with different liquors
i don't think so i think it's just booze
they don't do that with other [ __ ] on
heroin i'm good but black tar
but i will say though i think like a
wine drunk is different from the whiskey
drunk like i think certain drunks are
like i'm silly when i drink wine i'm
like it's more gossipy yeah like whiskey
i'm a little more sugar is that white
wine or red wine
same [ __ ] i mean for me at least but
whiskey is a different but i know you're
saying like tequila with like around
there
but i feel like vodka is a different
drunk but but not to the extreme i agree
with what you're saying not the extreme
of like i did something
you know
yeah
totally i'm with you yeah but i just i
really
enjoy watching people
um
use that to
like convince themselves that yeah
that's fine exactly like nope no rose
ever again no rose we are done with like
they truly are like no more don't need
therapy
that was the only problem exactly and
then just waiting no no no rosie i'm a
long island iced tea guy now yeah yeah i
do totally you know what it's important
it was the sugar so i need the i need
the potato vodka but
we're all of a certain age now i feel
like you've found your booze and you go
with it like what is your go-to i feel
safe with this drink i'm comfortable
with this drink i know my limits
i think we've all mastered a certain
you're vodka i'm tequila but you i
thought you were off tequila yeah i'm
back
i can't leave it you i knew you were
tequila i'm tequila and i don't have a
reason for it i'm sure it's just placebo
i've decided that i'm not a vodka person
because every bad choice i made has been
on vodka but it was also all in my 20s
so right yeah i'm like didn't blame the
vodka yeah yeah but i just like i have a
bat like do you have any like sensory
things where
you're not allergic to it or it
shouldn't make you sick but you just
have bad memory like i smell vodka and i
just think of like nightclubs called
like area yeah
yeah guys named taylor right guys being
like can you help me put myself on tape
like i just said like vodka like i just
i'm so that's not alcohol that's los
angeles by the way
i'm so sensitive with smells yeah i
don't know it takes me like right back
same same
yeah i don't know if there's one that no
alcohol really
coke is is very child that's college
southern comfort
southern conference dude have you had
mike's hard lemonade recently oh we used
to shotgun though it's awful dude we
were i don't know where i was touring i
feel like chelsea lynn was there i don't
but we went and mike's hard lemonade has
new ones that are like raspberries oh
yeah
and we just like it was so fun that was
good times smearing off ice remember
you've been iced and you would have to
drink it
they tap the top and then it overflows
and you're like oh that had a real
moment that was pre-white claw but
that's great branding like just frat kit
there's a game attached to your dumb
drink yeah and you have to chug it so
you need more and more and more do you
remember like drinking
it so much that you like looked forward
to puking so you could just start over i
never could do it i had friends who just
went
and they would puke and be right back
and i couldn't do it yeah i just
remember being like i really see i never
could make myself puke but when i would
i was always like i think i feel sorry i
was jealous of you people yes it was
like oh god now i can start again like
what kind of but you're just about
that was a anorexia
thing
that was a totally different thing um uh
that was just that was the one good
choice i made in my 20s
but it's just so weird to think back
when you were like we were just like we
just didn't know what we were i know
it's crazy to think how many years we
probably took off our lives did you guys
play power hour yeah well mark says this
crazy thing all the years we took off
our lives we have a drinking podcast
dude
it's still not healthy no it's not
healthy for sure and we drink it on the
road but the stress i mean you could
also make the argument that the stress
you would admit if you didn't do things
where you
chill good point i had this dietitian
like everyone's got their healers and
their [ __ ] stones and stuff i'm like
let me talk to a real dietitian like
explain to me like what can i eat what
can i not eat like
i'm just confused and she was like the
cortisol that you're going to admit
stressing out about eating the right
thing is way worse for you than just
having mcdonald's
interesting
[Music]
that actually is the like emits cortisol
that's actually the basis for the movies
uh super size me
so i just eated every meal then but you
know you hear about those old ladies
they're like i drank a pint of scotch
every day had eggs and bacon and three
cigarettes and you're like you're 98
yeah because you probably didn't stress
about it but we're talking about that
because that's an outlier that's what
we're talking about good point i mean
interesting oh you're that guy
i'm a pessimistic guy i'm still drinking
but i'm just a realist we're texas
people now
sam use all of simulation
we don't care about data get out of here
you're [ __ ] buzz kill
we're going to get you in one i am being
a buzzkill right now
or others call it a realist we are
killing ourselves let's enjoy it yeah
that's nice
that's it yeah
okay i think that the amount of stress
that it uh you know since it's not
making your life a nightmare sure like i
think actually makes you they say that
our life span is going to go down from
kovad not from getting coveted but from
stressing out i heard the same thing
like heart disease at 65 right and all
these kids are [ __ ] up because now
they have less social skills and yadda
yadda mm-hmm so i do see kids in mass
when i get sad like that is something
like they're missing out on great news
that you don't get happy or a boner
i didn't say anything about a boner yeah
i would hope so but also like maybe
they're preparing for the life they're
gonna have
uh yeah you know what i mean good point
true maybe they'll just be it you know
hopefully constantly i don't know well
you got to have a balance yeah you know
that's true like cosby
you know america's dead sweater pull
your pants up and then
the other thing that's kazzy's problem
he never found a
no he had a balance
have you seen the video of him leaving
the courthouse when he does the fat
albert impression i have it's a classic
i haven't seen that it's fun can we pull
that it is bone chilling he's still got
it because he the the it's more like
what goes into the thought of deciding
whether he's gonna do it or not is is
i heard he booked the role of a sexy
plane after this
[Music]
[Applause]
still got the voice down
this guy got a cartoon that's amazing
what happened in his mind right there
yeah
whoa that's up there with the kevin
spacey uh video remember that one but
was that a comic bombing who couldn't
bomb
uh
i wouldn't call that a bomb i just mean
that like he couldn't walk by without
making it yes yeah that's a comic you
know what i mean
that's like something at the end of the
day you're like my man
i mean funny till the end and he kept it
clean yes it's still a clean joke and
gave yeah
yeah
the l4 got involved that's good the good
thing about being a comic is weinstein
didn't have a moment like that he just
kind of sunk
yeah as a comic you get that one last
laugh yes point good point and it's so
it actually kind of like broke my heart
in this weird way or felt kind of
poignant because it's like
everyone i don't know we can always
pretend we're okay
and there's something kind of private
about i don't know there's something
kind of like cool really lonely about it
um but it's a force field you have this
defense mechanism at the end of the day
but i love the idea of him on this on
the trial on the stand like oh i'm gonna
do that
the fact that everyone's so mad at him
and he's like how do i make all these
people that already hate me laughs yes
exactly like i don't even care that you
hate me i still want to make you laugh
right that's all i know
yeah it's kind of brilliant he turned a
room he did yeah i don't know about that
hates you laughs that is nice it's
better than someone that likes you yeah
one time i got my mom to laugh
[Laughter]
there was something that you're right i
mean it's like it's just human nature if
you're hanging out with someone you're
like i don't think this person likes me
and you get them to laugh there's
something about that involuntary thing
it's also it's wild that our default is
that
people would pretend isn't that weird
but we do that
because we're the ones guilty of it like
people come up to us they're like that's
how this thing happened they're like
that's funny man good point we're the
ones that fake it the majority of the
time but what about the guy in the front
row doing this [ __ ] and you're like you
showed up you bought a ticket why are
you mad at me yeah yeah that might just
be them that just might be how they are
you know
i remember there was a comic who passed
away william stevenson he was like the
grumpiest guy on the planet i loved him
but he was never in a good mood and if
you got him to laugh like made your
night that was nice you know it was
something something about people like
that who were that because he meant it
you know you really earned that letter i
broke him out of this like grumpy [ __ ]
yeah you know the only thing about that
that i feel like i have to contribute
about the person in the front row the
guy that's like just staring you won't
laugh number one i'll take anything
above the girl who thinks you need a
backup
dancer or like to repeat your uh oh yeah
yeah i went down the street where'd you
go down the street cool yeah like
it's like yeah so i'm going through a
breakup oh girl i'm so sorry like yeah
preach anything's better
how about this guy they don't they don't
laugh they don't clap they do they do
this
or by the way true
i know
it's worked out leave me alone
there you go
and um that guy's okay
and also i think a lot of people get
nervous when they're in the front row
yes and they're scared and i never knew
that until truly
a couple days ago i was at the comedy
store and there was a guy that was
sitting alone and he was looked he like
wasn't laughing hard enough for everyone
else really was and i could only think
about him and like i'd understand why
yeah he agreed with me that the jokes
weren't that good i everyone thought
they were better than than they were and
um and i was like hey what's your deal
and he just looked at me and he was just
like i'm nervous wow
damn i feel like a couple years ago
he just was like said his feelings i was
like of course you are yeah
trained ninjas are coming at you exactly
with the intention of embarrassing you
in front of a crowd totally and we're
the only art form or whatever you want
to call it that people don't want the
front row every music show i got the
best tickets i'm in the front for this
band or whatever that's probably showing
a gig recently there was like an old guy
who's like i don't want to sit in the
front the guy at the door is like no
one's going to make fun he was like
please i don't think no one's gonna say
anything the second he sits down the
house goes look at this old [ __ ]
out of the gate it's not even original i
know
look how old this guy is like i am old
[ __ ] i was at the ice house once and
this is um i don't know what was going
on with this night but there was
definitely like some laziness going on
in comedy i don't know i think it was
just because there was like remember
when you were always doing showcases and
all whatever people do it's called los
angeles
and for whatever reason out of pasadena
i think it was before sort of comics
like us were really working out there it
was kind of like a random group that
wasn't really in the comedy store in the
improv circuit and probably more people
that did like i don't know like
i was going to say ships
that kind of stuff we'll hack casinos
yeah or just whatever roadier i was like
the fourth or fifth person on and i'm
like sitting watching the person in
front of me and uh the comic goes hey so
where are you from a guy stood up in the
middle of the audience and went he's
from dallas he's from tampa he's from
pasadena can you please just tell some
jokes i i kind of respect that damn it
was like that's like one of those
moments you witness in your life that
changes you yes forever i'll never do
that again that's when he gets on stage
he pushes you the other way he's like i
got this let me do it i'm the comedian
now hey hey yeah like forever change
yeah yeah yeah because everyone no comic
watches the other comic so then you go
up there you go i'll do some crowd work
it's always good to watch i always i
know we all avoid watching comedy
because you don't want to absorb [ __ ]
you don't want to repeat [ __ ] but like
it is good to watch the comic before you
just to just to see the room just yeah
being an audience member and watching
crowd work unless it's like your hero
right and like wildly just special for
if you're headlining a show and doing
crowd work it's very different than
being on a showcase and doing crowd work
100 it was people in a showcase over and
over and over why do i have to hear
about where that part like yeah
it's so insane when you think about it
yes make me laugh i bought a ticket i
want to hear some ideas some jokes and
you're just like look at this [ __ ]
shirt on the hobo i used to host the
caroline's you know i would i would host
there and you did too i mean oh yeah and
you really uh
you really i always avoided crowd work
for me crowd work was like i'll do it if
i have to but i would open with jokes
and if the jokes weren't hidden i'd talk
a little to weave into the jokes but i'm
like i'm the point guard here i'm
setting up the show it's not my job to
do crowd work
not a lot of comics think like that and
that's why you two are you because you
know like you know i see so many super
talented people that just didn't get
what i think they wanted because they
were really funny at crowd
if you're really good at it it's hard to
follow your own crowd work with yeah
sometimes and you're
you know i'll have another one the worst
one i ever saw was uh this is at the
seller i won't say who it is
but it was a lot of crowd work and he
was doing well he was killing but
he looked at a guy who wasn't laughing
and he goes what's your problem man then
he goes i'm just waiting for material oh
and the guy just
sunk he was crushed because it just cut
him to the core and he wasn't trying to
be mean but here's the other thing i'll
say
okay what do you feel there was material
that just felt like it wasn't or did it
feel like it was just like
super self-indulgent it felt pretty
crowd you know this shirt i'll talk
slower where you're from jersey you know
when it's great crowd work it can be
magical because it is like
someone you know has already proven yeah
they're great writers and you're like oh
well like the first time i saw daniel
tosh do crowd work
i had like a different level just of
respect for him because it's like his
jokes are so tight or whatever and i
kind of not that that's a bad thing
that's what i do too you know but i
remember seeing him do crowd work it's
like it's even cooler yeah because he's
a great writer
knowing that you could do with this the
shortcut todd barry is a great example i
mean yeah about like great you know
crowd but todd is great material and
then you see him do crown work and
you're like oh it's in the rhythm of
your act this is like just watching your
act right he did a whole tour that was
crowded that's right a whole special
yeah did you ever see the joke he used
to do about brad pitt
yeah it is it's in his presence right
the yes
you've seen that the guy the bone dry to
the bone
off the hanging off the bone todd is a
classic hanging off the bone i think
it's called what's going on with tosh
he's like one of my favorites he's like
this most most mysterious comedian
thank you
he's kind of mysterious isn't he he um
that's so good the cucumber makes this
by the way holy [ __ ] it's fresh it's
like a margarita but not too sugary i
love it right you put a little mint in
it it's kind of like
um i don't know
are you close with daniel tuscany i'm
not close with daniel tosh
no one is i know him from back top glass
was closed and i thought someone like or
like someone watson maybe
um
uh sarah tiana oh okay uh i think uh
candace thompson maybe would go on the
road with him but yeah i do know
seratiana opens for him and she's like
so normal and wonderful like he can't
share tiana during the roast battle once
said to me
i laugh at my own jokes and that uh it
makes sense because it looks like my
eyebrows are high-fiving ah
that's fun that's pretty good eyebrows i
am so into just savage insults right now
that aren't even too well thought out
yeah
those are called slurs
[Laughter]
like looking through this was a while
ago like some instagram like comment or
something and someone just wrote like
[ __ ] you you cancer hooker whoa
and i literally like laughed out loud
you're throwing words together that's a
one two but it's just like an unexpected
pairing yeah it's so mean that it's not
right right schwarzer was on my podcast
like a couple of months ago and uh he
was telling a story about marin which is
so funny he tells a story about how you
know like when you do mark maren's
podcast like he always opens with how
much he hates you yeah yeah
and he was like he was like i knew that
you know that happens with most people
but like we were like roommates we've
been like so close for like 20 years
like we live together and he goes on
marin's podcast and marin opens with
i've always [ __ ] hated you man
and swordsman's like what wow
what a piece of [ __ ] all those times we
like went to lot like
oh thank you like years we lived like
roommates i always [ __ ] hated you
like it just it was this hilarious story
i was just so excited to hear more that
i was like well and then and i sort of i
interrupted and i was like and then did
you and he was like if he would let me
finish
and then i was like sorry you're just
taking forever and he goes sorry i'm not
an adderall mannequin
damn that's great
marin had a bit i loved where he it
because it goes back to like we're
talking about the crowd and just
assuming they hate us and he had a bit i
think it's like one of his first albums
where he he saw this guy some biker guy
just like looking at him angry during
that he's killing for everyone but this
one biker looking guy hates him yeah
this guy [ __ ] hates jews like he's an
anti-semite i know in his head he's like
[ __ ] you jew boy and then he walks up to
him after the show and uh the guy's wife
is like oh you were so funny and the guy
he goes yeah what do you think and the
guy's like great show and he goes [ __ ]
that means that guy lives in my head
that's such a relatable bit that's deep
well that's all this guy is with the the
arms cross that's you yeah you just see
yourself yeah it's amazing
it really is i know it validates every
thought it's the insecure narcissism of
like i'm a piece of [ __ ] in the center
of the universe i heard you were married
i don't think he was he wasn't mean to
you
okay
no i'm joking no it's marin has this
ability and that was also so long ago
yeah that i'm sure i was not articulate
or i was probably scared or blabbing but
i i merit has the ability to kind of
like just destroy you with
something that's it's devastating yeah
yeah not ostensibly hurtful to someone
that's not in combat
yes so like a pin prick but only
comedians would get how mean it is yeah
exactly he insulted me opening forum one
i was opening from like probably 11 or
12 years ago and i remember i wasn't
doing great at one of the shows and i
busted out some like offensive jokes to
try to like be like [ __ ] you yeah and we
were in the car riding back and i was
saying like i did that because i wasn't
getting them and that's why i did that
and he goes i know what you were doing
[ __ ] killed me
you just there's him saying i know what
you were doing i was like
i was trying to explain it and he just
was like
that is so amazing he also called me a
hide the jew he's like you don't uh
address that you're a jew on stage
enough i don't get what you got to do go
up there with the yama obvious
but then i saw him years later in
montreal and i said i mention it more on
stage now because of you and he goes i
got to you
he lives in your head
so marin no i did his show and um we
were talking about comedy and he was
like so you like you like write like
jokes
i hate that [ __ ] you know what i mean it
was this was also 10 years ago when i
think i was definitely more
um punchy like set up
yes there was no fat and i really was
all about showcasing the joke yeah you
know and um it's like being a woman who
was physical was kind of annoying to
people like it was hard to have too much
energy so i think i was just trying to
like
be less shrill or something but yeah he
was like so you like write
jokes yeah
that's it it's just like oh like i don't
that's what he does too i think he's a
world guy try to be funny like geraldo
on colin yeah exactly yes i am here to
make people laugh right sorry i know i
did the work excuse me you just like
puns fall out of everyone else's mouth
perfectly well in the early wtf days
like it was scary to listen to the look
he would be really mean that was the
whole show it was just that tension one
was wild that was crazy carlos when he
did the car part two with mancia where
it's like he's like i wasn't mean enough
i'm going back
and i was like holy [ __ ] so
uncomfortable
not that not that carlos didn't deserve
it
exactly he's driving to los felix to sit
in his garage to get our spanking i know
that i compliment his house to tell him
back i'm like oh that's a nice painting
there has anyone showed up in bondage
that should be that should be really
good i was so [ __ ] allergic to he has
cats everywhere half i'm like was
itching swelling he's like did you [ __ ]
up your face with surgery i'm like i'm
swelling from your 900 [ __ ] cats
he's giving you an allergic reaction and
nagging you yeah
boomer
uh
i do love the podcast by the way i do
too my mom listens
my mom will call me and be like i just
listened to a marc maron podcast and i
was like what do you think she he's just
so neurotic and so unbearable i am like
and she goes and he's great yeah
it's addictive it's addictive i mean
ornie adams was on recently that was
just gonna say it was woo it was like an
old app riveting it was it was a great
one i gotta listen to that one
i love an insult where someone doesn't
even know it's an insult like um
jeremy piven was on a show recently um
at the economy store and mark maron went
after him and went
keep it going for the actor
see now there's a part of me that's
that's funny but i'm also like how come
you get to be mean like can we be mean
to you because if we're mean to him it
turns into a whole thing and he fights
back and he yells at you and i'm like
i'm just doing what you do yeah yeah
i think the business was mean mate yeah
i don't i don't know i don't get that
and yeah
i think
i think that if you if i think that all
comedians
yeah
i think we're fair for the most part
with each other like
you know because a great comedian has to
be self-aware so if a comedian if
someone's if we're like play-fighting
with each other sparring with each other
and someone really gets their feelings
hurt it's either you would i agree with
it or it just wasn't funny enough right
but i think if you're only sparring with
people that are at the same level of
your intelligence that you actually
respect so it doesn't get
is amazing it's gonna be tit for ted
yeah yeah yeah but he's i put him up
here he's a guy when i started he was a
big big dude big influence for both of
us
big fan yeah but then it's like the
[ __ ] on is fine i'm all for ball
busting but he's one of those guys when
you do it back all hell breaks loose and
i'm like well i'm just doing we're
different generations i mean i do think
there's a thing like when you did this
podcast i listened to you on him he
wasn't mean to you i think that when
there's a generation removed with him
it's different than someone he came up
with that's when he those are the people
he's mean to i think yeah so i do think
there is like what now [ __ ] right
it's kind of like that in a way which by
the way i mean think about it like if
that dynamic is any because it's like he
was the one that was sort of too edgy
for network or not sort of doing the
[ __ ] required to sanitize himself or
not the you know whatever the cartoon
like sick perfect paragon of like
whatever and then all of a sudden
sitcoms start dying and then he's doing
what everyone else thinks is a plan b
yep and it becomes the biggest thing yep
and then they're groveling to be on his
show
it'd be very hard to resist being a
little for sure no that's a good point
that's true i remember when you think
about all his friends that didn't hire
him yeah
in writer's rooms like think about all
the people he was an almost famous
do you remember the chevy chase roast
where like chevy chase i don't know if
you guys remember this but none of his
friends show up
todd barry was there todd barry was
great but apparently everyone bombed
that's what everyone said is like two
and a half minutes if you watch the
actual roast but i remember marin had
had a joke at the roast where he said i
heard chevy chase saying uh who are all
these nobodies he goes yeah we're
nobodies at the beginning of our careers
that's a [ __ ] biting joke jesus that
hurts me so much because chevy chase
like god like three amigos was mike we
were just talking about it i love that
movie it's tropic thunder pre-tropic
thunder it's my move i mean every time i
go out to eat it's like everyone around
me yeah like that do you guys have
anything besides mexican yeah yeah i get
out my dad when he picked me up from
school hide behind a car and go look up
here
it's a sweater plethora i know the whole
movie john loves rape the horses
so very old ones
yeah yeah the little plane with the
balls yeah sweet so this we're in in
famous
we're more than famous yeah we were just
talking are there any like bad movies
that you love
like like critically critically just
destroyed
anything ever
guilty pleasure [ __ ] can i tell you
something yeah mcgruber that's a great
movie excellent well i guess it didn't
do well but it's a that's true excellent
that's like the hardest i've learned
have you seen that i've never seen it
everyone i like likes it jamie it's so
funny it's amazing it is so funny can i
tell you what else is funny hit me
i'm thinking about it and laughing
because one time i was in la fitness and
it was on the tv and i had to step off
the elliptical the sound was off this is
you guys are gonna
hate me two girls one cup
paul blart molokai ah i've never seen
him it sounds off
kevin james is an amazing physical actor
i don't know if i just had low blood
sugar but him like falling off the
[ __ ] little scooter thing
yeah
yeah have you ever seen the um my
favorite thing of all time is uh um
[ __ ] um uh john ritter trying to get
in a hammock oh
yes yeah it's like three minutes of him
trying to get a hammock gold and it's
genius like i've never seen it can you
just do
uh yeah john ritter there we go and
you're like oh i know what this is going
to be like yeah it's not going to get me
it's it's god damn it it is so stupid oh
i can't wait i haven't seen this in
years but try to predict what he's going
to do it's everything is
like the first one you thought would be
kind of subtle right yeah yeah
he went so hard
like everything defies what you think i
love the idea of him practicing this off
screen like all right this is what i'm
gonna do first how much do you think he
practiced
because we've all been there with a
hammer i know but in his face it's just
like
it is so stupid
that's a throwback dude like on and on
by the way it goes on for seven minutes
or something that was network television
yeah back in the day that was good that
was a good time yes can i tell you i
remember um
the who were they jackie and what were
they no [ __ ] that's roseanne who are the
neighbors no janet
and chrissy yeah are you talking about
the laverne and shirley
oh oh three's company yes sorry yeah
yeah suzanne summers suzanne thomas and
susan summers she was like the first
actress right that was replaced on tv by
another actress the character was and
like
he just went along with it she went
along with like aunt viv can you imagine
doing that in the show today
just don't ignore what's the last show
the breaking bad wife is different
roseanne becky oh yeah you wrote didn't
you write for the first season i wrote
for the um the reboot the rebirth that's
crazy that was a huge show it was a huge
hit until it
was going away yeah i mean i really had
like high hopes for it you know roseanne
growing up was my hero like
you know that show made me want to be a
comedian
girl or not you know and um i remember
like growing up like i was always i
think there's something about i know you
guys like are really self-aware about
like anxiety and stress and like i know
i don't know what
is right for everyone i don't know how
to feel good all the time i do know that
when i
can see things that reflect my reality i
feel calmer
and i remember like when i was a kid i
was always like a super anxious kid and
super obsessive and i remember the first
time i watched roseanne the living room
i was like that's what my house looks
like right right it was just something
of like cause you know you always want
to know if you're normal yes yes exactly
back then there wasn't like any other
way to know and you would just watch tv
and it was like 90210 and all these
things and then i saw rosanna i was like
oh i'm it's like when you first see
other guys dicks and you're like okay my
dick's fine like
or you see another vagina you're looking
my vagina's not weird i still don't feel
that way
but i know what you mean but yeah look
at that that's like a midwestern living
room yeah that's an american children
came at the same time i was always more
of a married with children guy
personally yeah dude can i tell you
something oh bundy was just the truth
dude my hero i loved him with the tang
remember he would always make tang
sandwiches yeah yeah that show actually
now is probably even funnier i've been
re-watching it's on hulu really yeah i
watch it i need a comfort show before
bed so i watched something so
and i'm not this person marcy is so
funny too i mean it's just she's like
and all he does is call her ugly and she
directed like every episode if you like
she makes jokes that she has like a dry
[ __ ] and she's unfuckable it is like
the most hilariously like sexist show oh
yeah in a way that's like no ma'am no
man has ever been right right
men are like this is i know my dad hated
it but she was the first karen that was
a karen on tv was darcy oh my uh no uh
martina
oh yeah and then christina applegate yes
the daughter
was the kid they're all the virgins
yeah
she's beautiful and it's so funny that
he's annoyed that she wants to [ __ ] him
all the time i'm like she's hot she's
not gonna know it was hilarious
that like she's like
i know i know like the fact that it was
like what's your acting choice like i'm
just gonna be a t-rex like did she
did she do this
it's amazing speaking of flipping they
got rid of uh the neighbor guy right
that's another flip
but i think i think the second guy's
better
jefferson yes ted mcginley mcginley oh
that's right i think that guy was too
jewish they said really yeah no way
that's what i heard that's why i take
back saying he's better yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
were you uh
do you still talk to roseanne i remember
meeting her briefly and like being like
she's [ __ ] roseanne she's all out to
lunch she is literally like
we would do auditions to try to um cast
the girl that was going to play
darlene's daughter darlene and david's
daughter we had these actresses come in
and we're like oh let's have roseanne
read with the actresses you know like
see their chemistry and we had to stop
because everyone was laughing so hard at
roseanne like her lines were like hey
where have you been and she was like we
were
really i mean crying wow crying laughing
like she is so funny that it's like
it's um
like people
also not only she's so funny that it's
disarming she like i can't explain it
she brings out everyone's like
five-year-old because every whether it's
like she's been so famous for so long or
she's just this like has so much space
in your head that she's occupied for or
it's just that she her energy is
actually really intense yes yes in a way
that's not mean it's just fierce it's
funny you say that cause she was on that
show the green room and her and patrice
are like bonding and patrice is you know
terrifying and mean to everybody and
they bond and it's these two intense
people and it was wild to watch it's a
great episode that was a great episode i
remember you whatever who's the top of
the food chain two hyenas being like
god's exhausting having a yeah yes yes
exactly someone that's at your level and
you're like god it's so exhausting
having everyone be so scared of us just
because we're smarter right right
i remember in dangerfield's book he
would just talk about getting [ __ ] up
with her and going getting chinese food
in like midtown at like 2 a.m
like yeah we both like to eat that was
the whole thing like that's amazing like
that's those two she's been around long
enough that she like kicked it with
rodney oh yeah she was on the special
the young people they were a lot of
people were they weren't all close to
that true yeah you know so when we were
on the um show
there was like people would just like
disassociate they'd go they do time
travel when they were around her like do
you know anyone that maybe it's because
they're so famous or revered like
the way people behave around the person
you just see them all change sure either
they start being unctuous or you know
nervous or you know like when i um
uh i did not do this joke in any
specials because i know it'll get me
canceled and um get ready for someone to
say probably take this down at some
point
dated the black guy and all my friends
when they would come around him all of a
sudden they would just be bouncing
and i've known these people for 10 years
and they're all of a sudden like talking
like this and like yeah yeah bouncing
and i was just like i've never seen this
behavior like you are no wonder you
think white people are such dorks
i swear they don't do that all the time
you know that's hilarious i had a black
guy once say i like you because you stay
white
i didn't know what that meant but i was
like all right i look exactly yeah why
are you bobbing and weaving right now
like why and they overdo the hand thing
like watching one of my friends and then
like slow motion like like oh
yeah are they gonna do this one and that
one which one is it yeah
it's so clumsy around roseanne people
would just get clumsy and nervous myself
included the first couple times i
started but as soon as she talks to like
a comic
she wants you to feel like equals to her
like it goes away real fast but um she
asked this intern or some paid intern
um for she was like oh um i'll have a
coffee and the interim was like
she wants some sugar she's like yeah
just what kind of sugar it's like what
kind of sugar it's like just any kind of
just
any kind of sugar the girl comes he
actually only put ambien in it
i didn't know the [ __ ] was black
i thought the [ __ ] was white
the intern came back shaking holding
a handful of sugar oh
wow
and a cup and i just like looked over
and i caught it and i was like all right
sweetie let's just like back up back
like she was just like had taken sugar
poured it in her hand it was a panic
moment
and just kept moving like
i mean it's some kind of like offline
trigger of a trauma response yeah i'm
just upset you dated a black guy but uh
i remember when you were talking about
with like i remember i used to have a
sports show we went down to interview
basketball players and when alan iverson
walked into a room i've never seen adult
men just [ __ ] going yeah people
worship alan iverson like his vibe is so
it's like that jordan thing where people
were like it's [ __ ] iverson dude yes
there's also something about athletes
where they're this precious they're
these like adonis
very fragile things like i find that the
the guys that i know and i've dated that
really follow sports like they they
really worry about their athletes bodies
oh tom brady they're like what the hell
he's not even that buff so like like
when i like blake griffin and i did some
of the other and whenever he got in
public people like dude what are you
doing now man you should be sleeping
you know what are you doing what are you
what and they're like you know what
what's up with the knee is the knee
where's the brace like they're very see
we're shallow with men too it's not just
women is that tom brady that's what i'm
saying he's not even like yeah but he's
like a weird diet where like it like his
body doesn't look right but for some
reason i mean it's kept him working
obviously he's killing it is he
heavy or is she just that thin no he's
not heavy he's just like a little
non-defined when you're a quarterback
you need a little you need like you
don't want to look like us you need
something but he's got no death can i
ask you just tom brady wise like what
makes him
so great is it
it's something that can be learned
what's inherent talent and what's well
he was like a six-round draft pick i
think right or fifth what was it was
late and then it was a late he was a
late pick i mean that's the pick from
the draft combine look at that and then
he what happened was he uh looks like a
porn
drew bl bledsoe was a franchise
quarterback he just got paid for the
patriots and he goes down so um brady
subs in and they win the super bowl and
like that's how he rose to you know fame
but they were a defense first he wasn't
this great quarterback yet people were
like oh they're a great defense mm-hmm i
think i can answer your questions yeah
okay so i heard uh i was given a long
version i heard a center
be interviewed once yeah the guy who
snaps him the ball and he said i've been
playing in the league 10 different teams
or whatever
uh and no one ever spoke to me you know
because my job is just
hand the ball to the quarterback
and we're all in the huddle in every
down every time he gives a play and he
looks at me and he says perfect snap
and no one ever addressed me before
communication yeah well he yeah he took
him out okay
he took everyone out to dinner he
treated everyone well but like my point
was he was the beneficiary of already
built perfect team
and he and he wrote it's like almost a
comic who got gifted a great career but
then it was also great
it's almost like a guy who like was
doing comedy for like very people you
know what else sorry it's almost like
not that this is what happened like tony
hawk his dad just happened to like run
thrasher magazine what
i don't think that's true help me
give it a go sorry i don't think that's
true but his dad was very sorry
with me in the room
go please mark's a big tony hawk guy
he's uh his dad was very supportive and
tony hawk said it bothered him how
supportive his dad was i think he worked
at thrasher magazine or something
maybe because he was there was a little
bit of like tony hawk like
was like when i was getting big people
were kind of like oh it's because of his
dad
my dad can't help me do a flip i think
you're thinking of micro bigly his
sister worked for comedy central
is that true yeah but that's real that's
a joke but she did
but uh that's how petty comics are like
well you know his sister uh works for
comedy central that's how he got
everything but he had well and a point
he would he was built into a good
situation but then he still was great i
mean like he he wrote he was also at the
best coach in nfl history bill belichick
but but then he left and one with the
bucks i mean brady's the goat i mean i
hate saying the word the goat but he's
the guy he's good gwyneth paltrow her
dad was hollywood royalty you know who
like dana was her mom you know who came
to you know i just learned
eight months ago that nicholas cage and
jason swordsman are related
coppola the coppola connection right
we want nicholas can nicholas cage come
on here i know we're telling you to
harass charlie sheen to come on here but
we want nicholas page on this healthy i
can help out i did that movie with him
yeah the one that was just the
spectacular talent yeah yeah i heard
it's amazing
did you watch it no i'm dying to see it
it looks amazing but really quick what
was i just about to say about tony hawk
jason schwarzenegger no right
oh right before it shortly we need this
when you're pod with whitney you need
someone to like feed you where you are
you came to one of my uh my show in west
hampton mike tomlin
whoa the coach it was a big
deal you know how like you'll do a show
and like you don't know there's someone
important there but the vibe's weird and
then someone tells you later yes like
one time i was in spokane and i did like
20 minutes on the meth problem there and
it was awkward i was like okay i'm being
too hard on them and afterwards like the
mayor was here we're so glad you said
all that she really needed to hear it i
was like can you guys have told me that
right so it was like the room was just
so awkward and my tomlin was it's just
everyone i don't know if that's because
he was black or because he was mike
tomlin but uh could go either way the
hamptons yeah but there's a where
there's a being around an energy yeah
being around athletes people act wild
but being around coaches is like it's
like being around the pope interesting
people are
freaked out right we did a i did the
garden once with schumer madonna is
there yeah and i'm not like a madonna
head but it's still a [ __ ] madonna
yeah icon and she did five minutes and
it was horrible and i was like all right
donna did five minutes yeah
but she did a set no i think she was
trying it for me she didn't fallon too
and she did a set and i was like
before or after you know
before she went up you madonna opened
for you oh yeah and she looked great by
the way her ass would you i remember of
course did you talk to her backstage was
she like i'm doing no
no she gave me one of these
no i'm joking but i didn't i knew not to
bother her i just left her alone but it
was still pretty cool like that no one
ever bothers it's like why guys should
always hit on the hot chick because no
everyone thinks they can't right one
time i was at um some event for like an
agency or something one of those parties
that i'm like why am i here i'm not
nominated like my agents think i'm
amanda pete like why am i here and um
like people keep confusing me for other
people like and angelina jolie was that
i've never seen her in person yeah like
i've never heard of anyone running into
her she was there it was like back in
the day when she was with brad pitt and
she was sitting alone
for three hours wow three hours and up
and she was kind of looking around it
was like the year she wore the white and
like a red because i just remember
looking at her and being like oh she
looks like a she's in a different area
she looks like she's like from olympus
right right totally so i kept thinking i
like had a weird edible or something but
she was no one said hi not one person
that's fascinating famous people yeah
because i think it's like she's so
intimidating and i remember being like i
felt bad for her i felt so you know when
you said roomba get stuck under a couch
like a weird like sadness i was so
worried you were going to make the story
yes you the hot chick
[Laughter]
did you talk to her no i just i kept
checking in because i was like should i
go like say hi like
you know i don't know yeah
can i bring you a coffee with a handful
of sugar or something can i do maybe
this dart hits me in the neck
yeah so it was i don't think there was
like ill will it just like she was
looking around like just hoping i think
you're right that's probably why she has
19 adopted kids
she has to buy them she has to trap them
from other countries all right
whatever it takes good diversity yeah
i've been listening to a lot of the
rolling stones lately and it's been
great no matter what you like listening
to it'll sound better with raycon
earbuds raycon's everyday earbuds look
feel and sound better than ever they
won't budge with optimized gel tips for
the perfect in-ear fit raycons offer
three sound profiles noise isolation
awareness mode and plus mode whether you
want it immersed in sound or to hear
your surroundings raycon does it i use
raycon earpods they're they're awesome
oh yeah killer they give you eight hours
of play time which is pretty damn good
uh and a 32 hour battery life wireless
charging makes powering up a breeze get
the same quality audio as other premium
audio brands at half the price check out
raycon's wireless earbuds go to buy
raycon.com
might be drunk today you get fifteen
percent off your recon order that's by
raycon dot com slash might be drunk to
score 15 percent off by recon dot com
slash might be drunk hey folks we might
be drunk is brought to you by diet smoke
we're going to take a break and tell you
guys about diet smoke it is the solution
to avoid the oh [ __ ] i'm way too high
moment spin there tight smoke makes
delta 8 thc delta 9 thc and cbd products
that are perfectly balanced the gummies
drinks vapes are delicious they're
guaranteed to give you a beautiful buzz
you've been looking for without melting
into your couch the exact they extract
the thc and cbd from american grown hemp
and shipped directly to your door no
prescription no sketchy weed dealer no
need to leave the house dyed smoke just
released a bunch of new products and
flavors no matter what type of mood
you're in they got you covered if you're
ready for that perfect high head over to
diet smoke dot com use code drunk for
twenty percent off your entire purchase
must be twenty one and one to order and
older to order now back to the show love
you diet spoke hell yeah
summer is starting to wind down and i am
busier than ever that's why i'm saving
for saving time with factor factors
ready to eat meals delivered to your
house they make it easy to stay on top
of your schedule while still sticking to
your goals with factor a quick lunch or
a fully prepared dinner is just two
minutes away these heat and eat meals
are a lifesaver when you have no free
time factors new protein plus preference
makes it easy to power up with
deliciously satisfying meals and at
least 30 grams of protein per serving
factor offers 30 meals a week
change your order up every week choose 4
to 18 per week
pause or reschedule your deliveries any
time these chef crafted recipes are
packed with restaurant quality flavor
and everything is dietitian approved wow
stop spending your precious hours at the
store and in the kitchen let factor
deliver ready-made meals right to your
door each factor meal arrives prepared
pre-prepared by their team of chefs they
are ready to heat and eat in two minutes
they offer vegan veggie protein plus
keto and calorie smart options plus cold
pressed juices smoothies energy bites
extra protein veggie sides and more i
had these they're great i love those
smoothies
the killer go dot factor 75 dot com
slash drunk 130 use drunk 130 to get
135 bucks off
six boxes
that's code drunk 130
at
code.factor75.com
all right i hope i got that right yeah
it's go.factor75.com
drunk130 thank you
i brought um things that annoying
oh yeah look at you with your listeners
will love you man
peeves i have some very specific i'm
excited wait we gotta ask you some
advice later
because haven't you you've sold movies
right yes we're trying to write a movie
and we don't know what the hell
to do yeah you want to sell the movie or
you want to write it first well we're
going to write it because there's no
raunchy comedies anymore because it's
everyone's too scared yes so where's
like [ __ ] we're gonna write one make
one with ben shapiro
yes
it's a daily wire exclusive
alex jones is the lead yeah
[Laughter]
is jamie kennedy a daily live guy i know
because i thought i texted it to myself
and i forgot it this is embarrassing no
but like didn't he do one of those
movies
no jamie kennedy i wouldn't be surprised
you look up jamie kennedy didn't he do a
movie where they like hunt humans at
like a fake mar-a-lago or something oh
he did malibu's most wanted
he did scream
heckler
uh scream's still great still great
scream still holds up
that opening scene with drew barrymore
is so gnarly i love it it's great i'm in
the house well done yeah yeah it is
stressful every time yeah and she looked
great in it well the fact that she's on
the cover too so yeah and then she gets
murdered in the first scene you're like
what yes there's something like like
wild i remember how shocking that was oh
that was big but it still had like a
lightness and tongue-in-cheek to it too
when's the last time in a movie you went
like
i don't like horror normally so that's
why like your scream really sticks out
to me it's just such a good movie i
don't i don't know what you saw in the
theaters i hate i hate that type of [ __ ]
that look look do you like it because
you don't i know i don't find it fun i i
know people that love her i
it's like magic i don't like magic i
don't find being scared to be to be
exciting i don't like
thrillers i'm okay with but just fear i
don't like that i can ask you a question
are you the kind of person where after
um you get scared you get mad
that's my fate you know when people like
what the [ __ ] man i'm so embarrassed
i don't love magic but i do love
watching black people watch magic
should be its own genre
well they don't let them in her most
accomplished club so
all right what is oh should i read some
of them yeah some peeves hit us sister
um i put some down
this is the most organized guess we've
ever amazing i have like been talking
for like if i'm not making any sense
please tell me i thought it was talking
for two days straight and that actually
matters um people who as soon as they
get there tell you they can't stay long
ah that's a great one and they spend the
whole time telling everyone they can't
stay long yeah
everyone's like oh
like has to rush for that yes we get it
your presence is a gift you get it i
can't say i'm just stopping by sometimes
yeah it's a cameo you're lucky i'm here
anyway and then they're there for four
and a half hours and they won't leave
it's like the guy who goes i gotta get
up early and you go okay i'll switch
with you and then he stays the whole
night i hate that guy
yeah hate that guy no one's counting how
long you're here no
no get in and get out do an irish
goodbye if you have to
good one that's a good that's a good
peeve
um
what's your birthday august 29th
august 1st
that's a good one too that's a good idea
like she's trying too hard to bond right
right you know that's a great thing you
have to be like yeah
yeah
you leo virgo virgo oh me too
look at us
wow you guys are virgos it makes so much
sense actually i know such like autistic
weirdos um okay
people
who carry around a giant hydro flask to
show moral superiority yeah just that
they're better hydrated you know no it's
like i'm not using a plastic water
bottle oh hydro flash
but they leave it everywhere so
everyone's just trying to get it back to
them most of the time yeah right you
know the one that it's like they're
little a refillable water bottle yeah
yeah it's like
stickers on it yeah but also there's a
hydration element where you're like
you're better like mark and i don't
hydrate we don't drink enough water but
then then they'll open it and they're
like
you know it's like a thurman like you
can't even like you've never used that
before right
i had a woman stay in my place once she
left a giant water bottle there then she
came back to get it and she just didn't
take it
so i was like oh you're just rubbing
this in yeah people
like will bring their hydro flask
because they're so much better than you
and then everyone's just like did you
get it did they get it
and some of the the dudes have these uh
sucky things on it that really grosses
me out you know they're like good point
like all right all right get someone you
poured into your mouth
they're just not gonna babysit yeah
exactly exactly you did that like like
one beat like
wouldn't be too long that'll be a like a
gift
that last one was for you
i had to make him finish
you could have done two you chose to do
three that was just that's good these
are good peeves wouldn't they okay
people who um
uh post instagram stories like post
about things you're like guys this is
not sponsored
[Laughter]
this is not an ad it's just how much i
love this product like i'm not getting
paid for this and the product is
something that no one would ever they
would never hire people or need to
promote you guys
there's this it's called vixx vaporum
not an ad it's not an ad like for the
like they're not you know they're fine
without you we've heard of it yeah it's
like they got milk ad we all know about
milk yeah
golden joke people who sit through the
specials at a restaurant as if they're
watching macbeth
like as if
as if they're more educated than you if
they listen to her right right reduction
by the way this is me watching macbeth
no but like i mean more like how
seriously no i know i'm [ __ ] around
of their culinary expertise like just
putting this guy through a nightmare i
will call the special i'll i'll be like
we're good yeah i can't watch him do it
i can't either you've already made the
decision i already know i'm not gonna if
they're there you've chosen yeah it's
really just a test it's going can you do
you have it down right now that's
exactly right let's see let's see if you
[ __ ] up uh-huh and um so i yeah i when
people are like sadistic with waiters
quick quick quick side question whitney
what's your go-to cuisine hmm
because i feel like you you eat well
okay yeah a go-to cuisine like if i'm
gonna make it or if i'm gonna just like
order both something if i'm gonna make
it i really try to go healthy because
i'm like not like an amazing cook anyway
and it's point like i'll just do like
quinoa pasta and like
like healthy tomato sauce and vegetables
like i try to do that as much as
possible but yeah but literally it's
easy going out to eat oh okay any choice
ty ty really what's a good spot in l.a
uh
uh
though um i don't know what mine is it's
just like wooden hills it's like some
[ __ ] like minnie mouse i feel like
sometimes thai like not the worst it is
the better it is but the smaller the
restaurant like the hole in the walls i
feel like are always better you want
like a takeout spot jasmine i think yeah
actually when giannis came uh he stayed
with me and we ordered greek food he's
like let's see if greek food's any good
around here it turns out like the best
greek place in southern california is in
tarzana which is kind of close to me so
it was like it was unbelievable because
a lot of times out there you can get
really great food it's just not going to
be like in hollywood right right it's
going to be like like actually from an
immigrant yes yes you want some real
greeks yeah can i can i throw in a peeve
yes well before we get back how about
this guy something weird happens like at
a restaurant or a party goes
i guess i'm getting punked
you're not getting punked you're not
famous no one cares about you no one
made an elaborate ruse how about this i
was on punk oh were you really well
everyone said that to me for literally
eight years of my life uh i'd be like
running time to say am i getting punked
i'm like ah
you're not getting [ __ ] you're not a
celebrity i'm not like yeah yeah yeah i
didn't know you were on there yeah that
was like my i did the season that was
the season after he like pretended it
was cancelled right right how hot is
ashton huh he's really hot yeah he's a
good looking man he's a real he's like
handsome in a way that's like kind of
hilarious oh really very and very smart
he's like a very smart like business
brain yeah i heard that yeah you know
well mila kunis can't go wrong she is so
awesome yeah she seems cool she's like
ukraine you know she's she's what are
you crazy she's ukrainian oh i didn't
know that i think yeah it's so funny
that she's in like that she's just one
of the voices and family guy like what a
sweet little gig that's so cool
i love stuff like that i love like weird
money like hank azaria
like i've hit him up twice to come on
here and he hasn't responded to the
email and he has so much money we want
you dude yeah i've been watching brock
meyer that's a great [ __ ] show dude i
am such a big hank azaria fan dude he
did a movie called
uh about um john avnet directed it
oh it was about basically john abnett
who did um fried green tomatoes the
burning bed stuff in like oh god that's
amazing look how little this is
embarrassing oh wow
to the left right there that was it yeah
remember it would come up there oh yeah
yeah
so
wait where are you from dc virginia oh
okay wow look at that yeah that was a
2004
what's the movie that's a big break that
was a huge show i mean on mtv at the
time that was like kind of that was the
show is mtv still a thing no no kinda i
think it's got like shows that i guess
people maybe watch on like apps you know
like like reality shows or uh not a
geico catfish that was big yeah maybe
that i don't know mtv studios
i couldn't tell you where comedy central
or mtv oh the bird cage that's a great
movie oh i thought what movie were you
talking about thank azaria movie
okay no it was about the holocaust and
basically john avnet is a comedy john
abnett was annoyed that no one was
making movies about the um jewish people
that fought back
of course they didn't survive
but they were uprising it was about the
uprising so no one ever talked about the
jewish people that fought back narrative
is they just you know
went along with it just were submissive
and there were many many that fought
back knowing they were going to die and
it's a movie about wow a couple of those
stories it's a comedy it's uh no
david schwimmer's in it
uh hank azaria
it's really amazing all right it's a
drama but
it is interesting that basically they
just never
depicted jews fighting back that's a
good point yeah somebody must have you
know
mm-hmm um yeah it's hard to i mean
it just doesn't sound relatable to me
yeah but
i don't see a lot of diversity
i feel like we should cancel it no i
love hank azaria i mean [ __ ] we want him
on this pod my other favorite is like
jennifer tilly you know the actual
liar lives over broadway she
divorced sam simon and in the divorce he
was working on stupid money he was
working on the simpsons and he was she
wanted and he was like i don't have
anything like to the lawyer he was like
the stupid pilot i just did like she
could have
she could have all my points on this
stupid pilot fine
whoa
she's got like
an interview that she advised him
against the show
and he gave it to her as like a [ __ ] you
yeah that's amazing apparently she
actually just uh got married to the guy
who made squid games and they're going
through a
[ __ ] i don't divorce
um no that's crazy i love stuff like
that
like demi moore produced austin powers
what
sandra bullock george lopez
really yeah austin powers holds up hard
i saw that in the theater so hard it's
so good so they made three of them
it was great but the first one is a
masterpiece a masterpiece mike what
happened to mike myers colin quinn was
supposed to be uh seth green that's
right what yeah because mike myers colin
quinn did a a character on uh larry
sanders when he plays riptorn's spoiled
son
and mike myers saw him was like you need
to be this character and collins like i
got my own [ __ ] cooking around i don't
want to do it and i gave it to seth gray
yeah when you can't picture anyone else
like a million dollar baby was
originally sandra bullock
you know it's like the people that fell
out yeah you're like you can't picture
with the person neo is supposed to be
will smith yeah he said no dice and he's
like i don't get it keanu reeves is
actually supposed to slap chris rock
i thought it was supposed to be alec
baldwin dodged a bullet
there we go do you know alec baldwin you
know yeah i mean we did i did we did a i
was going to play his daughter at a tv
show really yeah like four years ago was
gonna call you a piggy yeah
was it cool what's the funniest thing to
do that is so funny i was dating this
guy that we it was very toxic
relationship yeah he was older had a kid
and you know
when you're dating like an older like
that's the older guy that i've dated and
when you think that they've done
everything sexually there's this freedom
to not try to impress there's nothing
they haven't seen he's seen childbirth
right right there's something liberating
like you've seen cellulite you've seen
hemorrhoids like you've seen it up pubes
like you just want to [ __ ] you can't see
it you know and there's a freedom to
that and so we had this like very funny
sex life that was more about like just
making each other laugh
like you know like his dick was dead by
this point and so
he had [ __ ] everyone like literally
everyone in hollywood that's the faces
dick was making right there you go to
parties and we go to parties i'd be like
her to oh like billboards
guess billboard i'd be like her too
you know so but it was like you know
there was there's a liberty in that yeah
you know you're not gonna be this
person's best yes like they've seen it
all yeah and um and so one time we were
just like dying laughing and i was like
okay one time during sex i want you to
call me a pig
but don't like tell me don't like just
just don't tell me when don't warn me
three months later i've totally forgot
we like had a couple of totally forgot
about it and he didn't even just like
take it you little pig
we laughed for like two days that's
great it was so funny i don't think army
hammer did that three months i was
taking a blanket bite my room
yeah i'm a hammer on the phone with his
agent am i getting punked right now
oh here it is once again i've made an
ass
of myself
trying to get to a phone to crown your
specific time
when the time comes for me to make the
phone call i stop whatever i'm doing and
i go when i make it stop matching 11
o'clock
i put the gun down
i'm leaving this message with you to
tell you you have insulted me for the
last time
you have insulted me you don't have the
brains
is this
[Music]
alec baldwin's tim dillon impression
[Laughter]
i hear this i'm just thinking he's a
damn good actor like the deliveries on
point every word is very decisive
same thing with remember when mel gibson
yes my lakers tickets yeah
the jew the yeah
yeah have you gotten into the wormhole
at all of um
uh
celebrity like actor auditions that have
been leaked oh no no i've seen a few
we've seen the chris klein mamma mia one
no what
from like american pie
yeah oh wow
oh the good looking guy
yeah he was the joker he was in election
remember that movie it's a great movie
this is for mamma mia this is rough
yeah geez see this is humiliating if
they ever get mine out i'm like this is
to be the worst can we make it big
i feel for the guy already
hey by the way you guys had mandy moore
in here she is an angel of all angels i
don't know if you guys saw american
dreams that her and i did together
where i too sing hopefully better than
here than i did there that was acting
this may be slight singing but she is
just a dream come true
on the spot she's amazing
anyway that's my own personal i love
mandy moore scenario let's go before i
embarrass myself
all right here we go
i wasn't jealous
[Music]
jesus christ
it is it's so ridiculous
oh
that was brutal
like what is what are our most
embarrassing things out there i feel
like
i definitely did last comic
driving
what huh it was like a spin-off that nbc
did as like an ad for last comic
standing we already we talked in our
last episode or recent whenever we
talked about it america's got talent was
pretty rough that was a pretty rough
look see i had never saw it you on there
really he did well but it's just just
they treat you it's just there's still
clips where you're like oh
yeah you know that any reality show is
the worst
tv thing probably what do you think mark
yeah you did his last comic that was
[ __ ] wrong pretty bad pretty bad you
try to churn up a story like oh my mom's
got cancer and they're like really
you're like nah nah last comic driving's
just you in the car doing materials
it was something that like was just so
weirdly
disrespectful i don't remember desperate
like i'm just thinking about the things
we were like oh we'll just do this it's
just going to air once and go away yeah
you know like those little things when
there was a comedy club on 14th street
remember comics with an actress
they had voss water bottles and i
remember going they are not gonna make
it yeah yeah they were actually just
rich vosses uh slime
that's all it was
23
[Laughter]
when you opened it it said your pussy's
loose
but i did the impractical jokers cruise
with rich voss and there was a bunch of
comics in there ari tim dillon a lot of
really funny comics around there giannis
uh yamaneika great bunch of people but
uh i remember someone came up to me
after the show and they go you were my
favorite and rich voss overhears he goes
oh yeah well your friend is prettier
than you
he's just got like 36 years of those
locked and loaded i know right he's so
good at the counterpunch he's the kid so
simple i remember one time um dice came
on at the comedy show this must have
been like six years or seven years ago
to me and he went on mondays is like
headliners pop in at like 10 o'clock
sundays and mondays
in the or and he went on stage and he
was like smoking like and just looking
around the crowd and there was like four
people there there's one in the front
row and her hair was up and you just
looked at her and you just went
take your hair down
and you're just like watching this woman
be like
she listens
it was so pimp in the weirdest way wow
also one of my favorite um jokes is a
rich voss joke i don't mind having sex
with a girl on her period i just pretend
like i'm killing her
i've heard that you've heard that old
patrice story about there's a couple
models sitting at the table and like all
the guys are freaking out talking to
them kissing their ass and patrice walks
up and it bothered him that the
the attention wasn't on him and one
model had a mole right here and he just
walked up and went what's that and
pointed to her and like hit it hit the
mole and she was like well i just uh and
now he was the alpha and it worked that
is so
funny
but cruel
that is so funny because we all have to
pretend we don't see people's moles
right it's like we just have to it's
like a full-time job to ignore most it's
insane to do that that's insane but it
worked one time i was with um this was
like before i like knew much um or like
like this was so crazy to me when i saw
it it was jeff ross was having like some
release of a show this must have been
like 13 14 years ago and we were at a
restaurant and it was like a premiere
party for his show on comedy central
whatever yeah and um
uh jim norton was there and jim norton
had j i mean had been doing open anthony
forever i mean was a legend but he had
just done down and dirty though oh yeah
hbo i remember that you were on that
yeah yeah so that's how i you know got
to know him and um and so we're standing
next to each other it's like super
awkward and this agent walks up to jim
norton is like jim norton like
you know kenny
whatever yeah bob lick or whatever it is
just trying to not say stein just trying
to not say a jewish name um that was
like so tricky because i want to say um
have you guys read the book what makes
sammy run
it's about a hollywood agent was it
kenny slotnick that he that's the agent
but it sounds right sammy glick sammy
lick okay um ben stiller's been trying
to make that movie forever it's an
amazing book
and so this agent comes up to to jim
norton is like jim norton like kenny
slatnick whatever it is and then jim
just went
where were you 10 years ago
dude it was wild that's great and then
just looked back at the party like no
one was it was only like 20 people like
it wasn't like a bumping party yeah yeah
and i remember like that's [ __ ] power
yes exactly you have to be funny enough
to be able to talk to people like that
right well that's what comedy is like
when you said you do that show in front
of the mayor and you're saying all the
[ __ ] about the town no one could say
that to the mayor but as a comic you can
get it out and that's kind of the joke
for him because we've also
we've also put ourselves out there as
fair
like we're like we also like
like if we're coming after you like it's
this is fair it's gonna come after
everyone yeah exactly and we're gonna
like do it in a smart thoughtful way
yeah yeah uh one another one of those
great lines is uh one time jim norton
was being interviewed for some kind of
red carpety
press thing and he go they go what are
you working on now jim he's like well
i'm on the radio show i got some road
work and i'm shooting um shooting and
colin quinn jumps in and goes i hope
yourself
it was just one of those perfect and
norton goes ah you're right what am i
doing and he caught it wow it was great
i love jim dude it was his birthday at
the cellar the other night and it was
just like cupcakes everywhere and it's
so weird you're like oh this is like
you you take a party like [ __ ] it's jim
norton he's a legend legend
and he's such a nice guy i remember when
he had that party at his home yeah and
he's like we never are used to like
you're so used to just you're on a show
and he's like zinging you we're in his
apartment he's like he's like are you
guys okay are you having fun it's a
mindfucking barbecue
whoa don't put that there
gotta picture him in de niro
also i i guess
there's something about when i take
nyquil i get in very deep dives on chip
chipperson oh
it's insane why but the more you watch
it the funnier it gets yeah well you
know what it is i've figured this out
because i'm a fan as well
norton is always aware always on edge
always sniping he could never say
something stupid because he would get
attacked this is just an amalgam of all
the stupidest things you can say
freely
that makes total sense so it's like it's
he's protected over this blanket this is
only dumb exactly exactly just dumb
because he never breaks character never
that's why
i posted a picture on like an instagram
story of just me and liz you know the
manager the comedy cell and we're just
drunk holding martini glasses and he
just responds and goes ugh i can almost
hear your glasses clanking subway and a
job well done you disgust me
[Laughter]
just inviting oh you hear whenever i
hear the word oh i hear norden's voice
do you guys know eddie pepitone well i
love her so it's like he's more like
more in l.a i mean great comic obviously
no like
if you haven't seen eddie pepitone's
recent special on amazon it's it's
incredible have you seen the video okay
yes obviously in a new podcast check out
his podcast yeah have you seen the video
eddie pepitone heckles himself
yes
it's amazing dude it is
so incredible it's brilliant it's like a
shitty venue in l.a do you even know i
can't even remember i don't know where
it is not knickerbocker knitting factory
or something there's not even that it's
worth it's worth it it's this is worth
it for sam i think it'll be a real
challenge this is the mirror thing he
does it to himself the validating
he's an incredible comment
staten island you suck
oh can you go back a tiny bit i was
wondering sorry this is very important
to me
i also i get uh
i get heckled a lot in clubs
um
and
it's usually generic
but accurate
like
pepitone you suck
but i was wondering
i was wondering what the heckling would
be like
if someone in the audience knew me
as well as i know myself
[Laughter]
i think this is what the heckling would
be like
takes forever yeah already a great
premise
he goes into the crowd i mean come on
how come you dream about red birds
attacking you at night
and birds attacking you at night what
the [ __ ] is that
your shrink says the red represents
anger on the inside of a woman's vagina
[Applause]
in the
morning that's an afternoon food
loving you
bacon at four in the morning i'm coming
at six in the morning you're coming
through medical journals
[Laughter]
it's also like
there's something like he never could do
that on a special i don't think he
could do it he could do it yeah i guess
you could but when i watch that i feel
like this was like for this
just to perform it yeah yeah i don't
feel like he's perfecting it for a
special no you're right because i saw
him do that over a few nights and it was
different [ __ ] he was yelling but it was
still personal that feels like it's just
for him yeah yeah i'm like what do what
do we do that's just for us it's hard to
just think nothing i'm always like is
this gonna clip it do i need to make a
tick tock
like what are the dumb bits we just do
just for us that's so true yeah i did i
was really bored at the end of a week in
tampa recently and on the sixth and last
show
i was like i'm opening with 10 minutes
of dead baby in hot car jokes and i dug
the fattest hole for myself i had a
camera guy with me i was literally doing
it to make my friend james webb laugh i
was literally like it's killing him and
i bombed for like the first five minutes
but around the five minute mark it
started to turn it was like i was doing
it you know when you do a bit so much
that it just starts to kill even if it's
not funny
that's what it was and then i was
telling them we got to find this footage
um
do you think the dead baby was more
awkward now because of what just
happened in the news
we're not allowed to kill babies anymore
no florida no it's florida no they don't
care that's my if you if you're getting
groans in tampa
if babies are going to die here it's
from crocodiles
and jesus that was a new story that
happened some woman fell in like a a
lake in a country club yeah eaten by two
darwinism
and it was huge crocodiles too she got
double teams
400 people have fallen off cliffs taking
selfies wow i believe it just that's
what we know it went through my mind i
hiked the cliff with my friend recently
and we're doing i was jokingly doing the
thing from hot shots too you know i'm
like a little further you know yeah that
joke that rowan atkinson does
you know what's weird when this is gonna
be in trouble that um when i heard that
alec baldwin news like remember when we
first heard about it the shooting yeah
yeah i remember going
i bet they were joking around
like i bet he was like
so much about me but i was like oh i bet
they were like to take a picture to be
like knee like just yeah yeah well
joking or [ __ ] look at al franken that
was
i was joking and look at him good thing
he didn't have a gun yeah but uh no that
was uh the evaldi guy was joking yeah
terrible joke hitler hitler
look you got to give him credit for
going for the bits
yeah that's a big part because some of
us commit yeah i'm going to get these
trains wait a second jury's still out i
don't think i've ever seen that photo
literally a bulletproof vest but she it
does look like she is
diverse
[Laughter]
is
liberals like to eat their own yeah i
guess so if this was a conservative
politician he'd would be no problem
whatsoever the bigger problem is that
cosby served her drink before
she shouldn't be that sleepy like no one
if al franken is in the premises and
you're asleep good point
like the celebrities in the room yeah
you're a narcoleptic
or i was watching that scene in sopranos
and ricciario was [ __ ] janus while
holding the gun and now i just think of
the alec baldwin scene like that
explodes oh yeah that's a good point
whoa
i don't think dude it's a weird kink did
you ever see
the beast of no nation movie mm-hmm is
that it
but yeah yes it was that guy carrie
fukanaga who recently had crazy stuff
yeah people are mad at him right i don't
know what happened with him yeah what
what can he keep up now there's so many
cancers yeah it's a great director
though brilliant oh my god
he's a true detective
that one long shot that everyone talks
about well in beast of donation he did i
mean it was like a seven minute shot
like in like the trenches
right it was the one where you just
elbow raped the boy yeah yeah and then
you're gonna see this movie there's a
scene where a teenage boy
shoots a woman or is raping a woman and
a guy shoots the woman as he's raping
her and he's like what the [ __ ] man it
was originally spacey
dude it's a wild it's a wild scene
really yeah i've never seen anything
that brutal on camera before except like
irreversible i don't know that yeah
rapeseed monica bellucci yep eight
minutes straight don't check my hands
don't check my browser history yeah no
no she would i mean she was like so hot
i remember her i never saw the movie i
remember
we already
ever i said kim bates i'm obsessed with
kim basinger was so hot i remember like
48 uh or nine and a half weeks or less
and michelle pfeiffer is not in your
time she's hot
to me she's not i mean i think kim
basinger la confidential is like at her
hottest yeah that's won an oscar too
she's so good man batman was right right
who's your hottest smart like not like
top
couple so you don't panic what do you
mean a couple like top three just so
that you don't oh sure
okay well i mean angeline i know it's
hack but she was gia when i first saw
gia hackers can i tell you something she
was like a little less skinny yeah or
not because she was she was like less
gaunt yes yeah and it and less severe
yeah playful and feral right that movie
is incredible incredible movie
not hepatitis from drug use and she died
and she was one of she was a supermodel
i thought that was the truth that i
kicked off the mandalorian for a second
who is that that's gina
carrano
okay this is gina carrera what's her
name gina carrera
yeah that sounds right all right
gia oh gia sorry what is it gia
famous model she was a famous model i
guess in the 80s who got aids from doing
drugs got it
and she was a lesbian remember elizabeth
mitchell was the lesbian lover in it she
comes out topless and you're like
amazing cans yes amazing cans that by
the way aren't symmetrical oh
i mean they're like kind of sloppy and
not like a little lopsided do you know
what i mean yeah sure of course i know
what you mean i remember going like i
hate myself because that's her face but
her okay now i gotta see these lopsided
knives gia karanji yeah that was her so
she
so she died she died of aids was it aids
and nobody knew what it was
at the time damn yeah eighties it was in
its monkey pox face right hey right
uh yeah
agent aids related okay yeah how
supplies together i'm trying to think
sharon is coming in he's down on the
street badly beaten and raped she was
like a homeless drug addict after being
like on the cover of vogue whoa
she had some great cans hold on that's
not her no no look at do topless
angelina jolie yeah yeah leave these
peters we because we don't want to lose
the content but we do need to bleep some
boobies email me the link well you can
rubies buzz them out or just block them
out or something none of those are her i
don't think no oh that's the real one
oh because i remember that scene that
was a famous scene trying to think mark
who are your top i don't know i got
weird well i changed weak do we oh yeah
look at that
yeah look at that it's like my sack
the right one is the left one is longer
remember that and i remember being like
it's weirdly hotter that they're a
little
yeah lopsided it's more real yeah i
thought so i like it some other mugs
john voight's daughter jon voight's
daughter
and her look at can you google her mom
her mom is uh what is her name genevieve
or
micheline
micheline micheline uh i don't know
so beautiful likely in black that's in
my top three
no
oh wow she's gorgeous can i tell you who
is so gorgeous that's the mom jesus she
might be hotter than angelique i know
right wow
um who i think is really hot
just blank
tammy
i'm gonna
i'm gonna remember don't look at me
first all right you know what ah
kelly little looking at her [ __ ]
stupid face uh it's so perfect um um not
blanch it the other one kate blanchett
kate winslet
kate beckinsale yes yeah she's up there
okay so okay we forget about no we
forget about her because she knows she's
so hot we don't forget about it pete
davidson made it attainable made her
like oh not attainable but uh like oh
she's human she [ __ ] me david what
about are we taking personality into
this are we just talking oh no no no
come on what okay but if we're taking
personality you got to throw julia louis
dreifus in the mix
oh if we are taking if we are we're not
taken personally okay let's keep it
objective
um chrissy turlington i think is the
most beautiful woman that ever lived
what who is the one that billy joel used
to hook up christy brinkley she's
[ __ ] hot see i'm not a black
like blondes with skinny lips to me you
guys just want a blonde and you're
willing i feel like how high you have to
be for a blonde face wise is so much
lower i remember i remember amy schumer
took me to a knicks game once and we
were in and we're in the room and i
remember uh seeing her and be like man
who's that hot chick and she goes are
you kidding me you know and she was like
that's [ __ ] christy brinkley
she's like she's like she's like 65 and
i was like what
uh christy brinkley yeah no christie
blink brinkley yeah elizabeth she's the
one that had a sister who died uh oh
elizabeth she had a sister who like died
in a drunk driving accident oh wow so
that's chrissy billy was driving up yeah
not down to the like how about second
one to the right down one
yeah i think catelyn shed is [ __ ] hot
she's very pretty yeah she's hot in a
way that kind of intimidates me though
me too i wouldn't be able to get hard i
would just have to appreciate it like a
painting you know yeah you're kind of
just like
um artsy hot yeah
but did you see nightmare alley she's so
hot now oh really i haven't seen it um
not a great movie but she's so hot now i
don't think i remember
i don't think i remember you know who
else is hot in a way that i can't
she feels a little mousy to me but
there's something there's some reason
you can't stop watching her is um
uh
my god what is everyone's [ __ ] name
nancy pelosi
did you see that picture of her i did
that was insane he's such a [ __ ] the
heavies i mean
he's going hard on that
now that like the butts are in he's back
to the kitties
are you are you a butt or a tick guy i
like both
yeah why do we have to choose i know
exactly
i don't think i think both are great we
don't you know what we are holding fake
tits we're not holding a fake post here
you guys is there a like a looking down
upon fake tits no we're [ __ ] with
someone we love them we got sent them in
is this uh what is this is a silicone
this is from trey parker's wife uh
she sent this in these into us were they
in her body no she makes them she's a
surgeon
really boogie parker is her name right
yeah she's awesome why does he get
cooler every time i hear him
he's married to a surgeon i know i will
say i think the south park movie is the
greatest comedy of all time oh which one
the bigger longer and uncut it's a
musical it's just
america no no that's the team let's see
america that's great that's incredible
too
damn hold on i had a hot lady where
we're losing yeah give me a hot lady
mark hold on um no the girl from ferris
bueller's day off
oh yeah she's cute i feel like that was
kind of a moment
i'm advocating for burnouts
who's the woman who's in uh woody
allen's love and death what's that
actress name she was so hot
well scarlett johansson very hot but we
know colin so that's weird oh it makes
it awkward she's pigeon toed
by the way you know what jennifer
connelly yes underrated but how big of a
deal is like
having a crush on them as a child matter
no i'm okay with that you know what i
mean i joked after drew barrymore and
e.t constantly
no no dude the child thing is definitely
and hopefully like natalie portman like
someone you've loved for so gorgeous
yeah you know but alyssa milano less hot
now
who's the boss you're like hey she's
cute now you read her twitter you're
like i can't get hard you know what i um
uh i there's this comment
oh yeah very pretty there's this comic
uh i used to mark mealy who i'm used to
run around together and do open mics and
um he did like really smart one-liners
and uh he just said dude who's that
that's what i'm talking about oh yeah
yeah love and death and he would go um
he's like you know look up angelica
houston young
i don't know he would go no she was hot
playing with fire now really i don't
know who's just kicking in dude if it's
good enough for jack nicholson it's not
good enough for mark norman
i don't think we're talking beauty yeah
when she was with um beautiful jack
nicholson yeah she's beautiful put her
next to jack nicholson so they think
she's hotter exactly
um like she's got this she's got
something
she's like really thin and wafey in a
way that i don't even think is sexy but
because she looks like a weirdly
gorgeous she's also hollywood royalty
but she's like a transylvanian
vampire domination she looks like
marilyn manson
no she's beautiful
come on hello jack are you attracted to
the young jack or now
at least from a cool factory
carnal knowledge is when i fell in love
really yeah wow okay and i i'm half i'm
pretty hot there he's very hot huge dong
really yeah he [ __ ] a couple porn
stars they went on howard stern and they
talked about it i didn't know that um
really quick the the uh this comedian
used to do a joke he's like uh the other
day i went to the bruce springsteen
concert and tony danza was there and i
was like dang who's the boss
so you you do like him a little bit what
tony danza tony no no that was just a
joke what you were talking about but
he's a handsome guy tony danza i think
that don't tony
taxi tony danza if you want to talk
about low-key hot guys please because we
don't know bon jovi
low-key he's a rock star no but like
low-key hot dude bruce springsteen
what do you guys think guys i'm gonna
throw a curveball at you paul mccartney
yeah but i don't think he's hot i think
he's talented he's not like a heartthrob
bonjour he's a good looking guy bon
jovi's like a heart he's pretty yeah
like that that's hot to me interesting
just like
i feel like we got a shot at getting him
on my other podcast i'm do i start a
podcast with julian edelman the football
player and they're friends so if you
want to talk ask him about opening
question yeah uh oh my god that's such a
funny idea for a podcast just everyone's
saying like if we could get this guest
what's the funniest question to ask that
yeah he had one question for him i want
to go what happened with pepsi clear
was he on that no right now hey
that was the song that was a song
was the biggest thing he must have made
a fortune on that publicity stunt yeah
flop big flop flopped you got bon jovi
you've got pepsi you've got clear damn i
just want to be like what happened who's
that [ __ ] that postman only rings twice
what movie is that such a stud
you know what's weird is axl rose sang
for surge
[Music]
um i'm um people always tell me i look
like the woman from the shining uh kelly
duvall shelly duvall gave an interview
to
dr phil
seriously she did it she looks she looks
like kind of recently yeah yeah oh
because she did a she moved to montana
and she talks all about how uh kubrick
treated her and really
and not in a way that's like shitty or
i'm trying to cancel him it was like
this was his process and he would keep
me up all night and scream and he
wouldn't let me sleep
he used to make tom cruise walk through
a door like for one shot just to get him
walking through the door he said to the
dp and everyone like have him walk
through it 80 takes and then come get me
because he wanted so badly for him to
just be like
truly annoying yeah yeah because he
didn't like other ways to annoy people
you don't have to just waste people's
time i know right he was trying to like
humble tom cruise because tom cruise was
a huge star at the time
and he like wanted to [ __ ] up their
marriage and like so much of that movie
the fighting is like real and they
divorced after like he really got off on
like like abusing actors and another one
and it didn't even do well which is so
funny it's a good movie though acting
was good her acting in that is the
acting is great legitimize her as an
actress yeah no she's incredible have
you seen to die for yes she's very good
at that that's a masterpiece um i know
uh and i was talking about this the
other day because i actually
not that we need to hit women like
answer each other but sometimes it's so
fun of course um which is naomi watts
kind of they were best friends and naomi
watts did david lynch's um mulholland
drive and then nicole came into that and
i kind of feel like naomi watts remember
when she did was it eight pounds like i
felt like she was gonna be the next
meryl streep she was blowing up oh yeah
oh yeah she was in a lot of stuff and
then nicole kevin kind of went away with
the scientology thing people kind of
lost respect for her yeah she's not a
scientologist i thought no that's why
they broke up
oh is that right i assume she was isn't
that what ended i think her dad is a
psychologist and that's why i was like
she's a like a problem person or
whatever they call it
or sorry suppressive yeah something like
that
but katie holmes
that happened for a while she's uh
she's a great actress yeah she there's a
great movie that she was in called
pieces of april that actually it's good
it's actually like i watched it when i
was i think
like dealing with my like daddy daddy
love me like trying to figure out a new
family and i had like a thanksgiving at
my house for like my friends and like
dad's not showing up like that's what
the movie's about this girl who is all
[ __ ] up and she went to rehab and
she's like
trying to
make it all go away by making like a
nice thanksgiving dinner at her shitty
apartment yeah
the family does it's like you decide i'm
gonna stop being mad and stop drinking
and but your family
doesn't understand yeah yeah of course
you know when you've done all this work
to change but no one else has that yeah
[ __ ] stays toxic yes do you know her
katie holmes no no but you know that
like moment where you realize like
oh i've done all this work y'all are the
same yeah of course yeah but then they
still but they can bring you back down
do the [ __ ] if i do any of my
if i use any of my tools here you're
just going to think i'm being an [ __ ]
yeah yeah what do you think you're
better than me with your therapy your
college goals oh you're really
boundaries really yeah oh you can only
stay for seven hours okay tell me more
about freud you piece of [ __ ] yeah
so it's like yeah everything like when
you get healthy the sick and angry yeah
it's about that whenever i go home i say
i have to leave soon
[Laughter]
don't get used to this magical charisma
being around yeah now let me ask you
that you're a lady oh you got a lady
part
where do you stand on these guys who go
uh hey if a woman doesn't have a kid by
40 she's gonna shoot up a post office or
whatever the hell it is what do you
think about that i don't listen to tim's
podcast
uh i've not heard that that's a thing
like a scientific theory people have uh
um
i think uh hot take i think was just a
scientist mark just listens to jordan
peterson he's like a lot of scientists
are saying this i've heard i've heard
people say that i'm actually working on
a bit about this i just why can't
comedians just
like have a conversation i am working on
a bit about this so if it's funny just
no i'm not trying to make you laugh i
just happen to be working like the
spiral
um but uh about like uh
my guy friends who like the more
someone has been like fired from
prestigious establishments the smarter
they think the person is interesting
they'll be like this person was fired
from three universities
disbarred from being a lawyer kicked off
twitter kicked off instagram and youtube
removed from the chair of every
foundation he's on
he must know some [ __ ] yeah this guy is
smart yeah like it's just sort of like
the more shunned someone is the more
like a rebel galileo galileo he said the
arrow the world was round not all of
these people are ahead of their time
some of them are just problems yeah what
is the
jordan peterson i'm not saying i agree
i'm just saying what do you think is a
woman oh that's your opinion as a woman
i think the worst thing we can do is
bring more
kids in the world
to be like
to people who aren't ready to fully
parent not selfish there's a lot of that
nick cannon you know
nine kids yeah do you want to work to
your 105 i know what is it also
my question is like
what why nine nine isn't that's three
more than the brady bunch it is there
was a show how that was too many good
points you had three more it is one
thing like why can he have nine kids and
it's cool i have nine abortions it's not
good
elon musk too he's got about 12. by the
way i know i'm going on rogan this week
i know i hope this doesn't come up
because i know that they're friends or
whatever but like i feel like anyone who
thinks there's a shortage of humans is
just someone that needs like hasn't
flown commercial in a while
like it's also like maybe people just
don't want to talk to you like he's like
there's no one around right you're
looking around this place is dead it's
like i think it's like everyone's
working from home traffic is horrible
yeah yeah yeah it's just like i don't
think he sees that many humans because
either they you know
whatever his life is when you live in a
compound you're not a grocery store
right not think we need more humans no
we're good also why does every girl he
procreates with have eyes so far apart
um i didn't notice that well he does
want to go to space maybe this is going
to feel like he's trying to make little
aliens have you seen look at the girl
that he broke right he's look at
tallulah right that's just him his dad's
knocking people up too his dad's like 78
he's still dumping rice
that's right yeah
i don't know dude it feels and then and
then he's doing that neural link thing
what is that neurolink is what i'm sorry
joe brings this up every five seconds
he's obsessed with it wow
her eyes are far apart no okay that's
tallulah riley now look up how old is
she
girl who she was great at mars well
here's the thing grimes looks like john
travolta in galaxy
look up grimes and elon musk what was
the one where he had the dreads
oh batman
not battlefield earth yeah yeah
galactica holy [ __ ] battlefield earth
yeah so everything travolta's made some
turds huh yeah yeah dude
remember the general's daughter he's
made some real [ __ ] stickers yeah
broken arrow
yeah
but what's the but but pulp fiction
can't beat it no it's not but but
michael
but phenomenon
he's still great i'm just saying there's
a lot of bad ones in there too
but
greece
greece saturday night
he was like he was kind of bowie level
uh like like with those the um
the bg's stuff it was not not homoerotic
it was a little freddie mercury asked
look back and you're like
is he is he hotter that you know that if
if a woman slept with him you know he
wouldn't enjoy it does that make him
hotter he is a whole thing he's like
unattainable here's the thing i saw him
one time at a place called the peninsula
in los angeles it's a fancy hotel i've
never been to a friend of mine had her
baby shower there
he was there sitting in the corner and
so i've i spent the entire time walking
past this table to try to get a glimpse
of him like at my friend's baby shower
like walking back he's
stunning he's really
fully bald i didn't know if it was like
work or or steroids or hgh or just money
you know when you like see someone and
they just look like
well preserved yes yes he's gorgeous
what's the most recent movie he was in
that looked like the worst movie of all
time you know he's so gorgeous this you
reminded me when you snl one time i saw
blake lively in person
and i see her in pictures and she's
obviously a 10 she's gorgeous but when
you see a person you're like
like no like
i can't explain it there's like a beauty
that is like some people the camera
loves them yeah people just in person
loves them what about will smith once
and it was to say his skin is perfect
he's tall he's muscular he just lit up
the place what about ryan reynolds is he
like a really hot guy do you know what's
crazy about ryan reynolds i i feel like
i'm biased because when i was in college
this is so embarrassing i was the
correspondent for the entertainment
correspondent for the tv station like
the college television station which is
so [ __ ] dorky because it was like i
was shooting it on a k it was for me to
get like a reel i don't know how when he
did that movie van wilder yeah he came
to colleges
i got an interview with him i don't even
know how it happened i couldn't even
tell you and i went to his hotel room in
the four seasons i'm 18 years old like
hey do you want to talk about the movie
he was
wonderful really it was just like where
it was so awkward and i didn't
understand that it was awkward i was
like anyway so what was it like with any
pranks like i took it
no one has ever gone to john travolta's
hotel room at the uh four seasons been
like that was wonderful
no one ever
also the plot of peace and donation
and like he was like i can't even he was
almost like i can't explain it i've
never run into him since or anything
like that but he was so
i look back at that situation and i'm
like even if he most guys that weren't
creepy that would be a weird situation
like he was overly cool to where he made
it feel
fine oh yeah he seems like a regular
dude he's funny on twitter
he's struggled for a while and his
career the only thing that is so wild to
me and because here's the thing this
proves you can make mistakes maybe
so i have this theory it's not theory
it's just like uh
like when so many of the people we know
my friends you know they'll be like we
can't even hire these young kids in the
office they want to take us to hr and
they say that it's a toxic work
compliment and i'm just like why are you
taking the meeting yeah inspire them
like you don't like sue i don't know
okay
two
like everyone will know the truth right
i would rather go to war with you you
tweet about me and everyone will know my
character yeah you know or they won't so
it's like when this uh when ryan
reynolds he got married at like a slave
i saw that
and it was like anyone else i feel like
that would have buried forever right
posing at his wedding in front of a
plantation
housing oh really
like
slave huts it's like in south carolina
or something gorgeous
they're very pretty and he was like i'm
really sorry when we gave him the
benefit of the doubt because he had a
record of being
not shady and we just feel that he's
like you know yeah same thing with i'm
like what you bring this back up it
sinks him right now this would be great
so like he did what yeah ryan reynolds
he did apologize he got ahead of it
before the backlash and i think that was
smart whatever he did was perfect yeah
like that's how to do it i thought it
was weird she didn't pay anyone who uh
catered the wedding but you know
um
not saying it not saying it
yeah holding back not saying it not
saying it all right um but know that i
could make you laugh right now if i
wanted to did you notice that everyone
at that wedding when they were around
the the caterers they were just like
bouncing they were just bouncing like
this
off of the bodies
um but uh so yeah i think that like uh
all right i'll see you guys next week we
gotta wrap this thing up here
i know i could talk to you guys forever
i feel like i'm like rambling oh you
didn't know right
what do you think
oh yeah we've done bits oh yeah all
right we gotta we gotta go quick oh [ __ ]
you just oh like new bits you guys are
working on yeah just a premise a a raw
uncooked half-baked idea i like trans
people
that's good stance okay
stick with me all right
i just feel like
i believe i i friends there are 35 and
they transitioned to be a woman at 35
they knew it four
no man would ever commit to anything
that long
that's funny like something and there's
something in like yeah that's how we
know
um guys don't seem that bothered about
them phoning it and god forbid i like
trying no that's a good that's a good
problem like just something about like
guys aren't worried about trans men like
women that transition you never hear
about that like women when they
transition to men guys are like well
that's just smart right right it's just
a good business move yeah the commit
thing is great because you know the guy
the perpetual dater guy who won't settle
down he can't settle down a gender he's
like ah i dabbled with being a woman now
i'm back i don't want to commit yeah
it's like oh you finally found someone
yeah exactly yeah and then maybe i was i
just have like this whole like just kind
of just trying to go the other way of
like uh trans women in sports like
was women's sports going so well
like was that like a thriving business
true you need the numbers yeah like if
there's like a trans female comedian
who's hilarious i'm like have you fully
not totally
you're with us but like well we yeah
like we need as many you know i'll take
whatever i can get right we're not like
you have an advantage because you used
to be a male comedian i'm just like
you're with us [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
like um the wa could use some dunking
that's all we're seeing
i was thinking like i'm allowed to make
fun because people get a little grony
around it like i feel like i'm allowed
to make jokes like this because being a
female comedian is basically like being
in the wnba right
no one wants to come see us it's like um
but then there's something to me about
like oh like i think we i think what
someone needs to do is just acknowledge
that like
trans women can be dicks like i'm
friends with like i know they're i they
are
because they're just living life as a
woman for the first time and it's it's
they don't understand how
stressful it is oh yeah a girlfriend of
mine like you know she's trans she'll be
like i just went i just had a hate crime
happen i'm like oh my god like what
happened she's like a man that i don't
even know wrote a comment saying that
i'm
lying unfunkable [ __ ]
and i was like congratulations your
transition is
hey that's great
you sit with yeah you're a woman now
like this is you lost the hymen yeah
yeah it's broken like this is like i
mean this is really brutal but like just
the idea of like um
you know like trans it's their time to
be they're still in their um they
haven't got to their like flat stage of
womanhood yet they don't know that like
women now we all dress like bull dykes
right like and you guys are [ __ ] up
the bell curve like why are you in heels
like no one does this that's true they
always go hardcore stereotype ladies
which is why you're in a bad mood
like just kind of like so girl because
my thing is like guys you don't have to
do anything about like we'll handle this
this is our problem like they're taking
our prizes they're taking our men woman
of the year we know just give us a
second to psychologically [ __ ] with them
to where like we we will do what we do
with other women we will make sure they
have no self-esteem left and if they
keep taking our awards we will call
tanya harding out of retirement or like
something like we know what to do
the problem is all you women are
supporting these women they're not
officially women until you guys break
off into a corner and are like that's
that's when they're fully women yes
exactly right that's funny yeah that's a
good point i don't know it's not a full
woman until we can make fun of you and
trash you and yes yes yes yes yes yeah
but it's also funny oh maybe it's
something of like when trans women come
to me and they're like men like hate us
i'm like
what do you think we think no you think
they hate you like the fact i hate you
it has nothing to do with you being
trans it's just yours that's interesting
a little prettier than me and i don't
like you think that was bad right you
know like i think there's just you know
someone needs to just be able to say
like yeah like they can be [ __ ] too
like you know drag queens everyone's
like drag queens are
molesting our kids it's like i have a
lot of drag queen friends like
like drag queens don't want to [ __ ] your
kids they won't even hug their own
friends
like i can't even get my own friend to
hug me you know like it's just kind of
more of a there's very they're very
distant people and when um when people
complain about their kids like my kids
get molested by a trans person or my
kid's gonna get blessed by drag queen
like all you're doing is like telling
everyone
that you think your kid is hot
he's molestable like you think your
kid's worth going to jail for right
right yeah trans are already tiptoed on
ice you know they're already on
eggshells now let me [ __ ] that kid
[Laughter]
that'll make my life easier
also like whenever a kid is in a
bathroom you're just annoyed just like
ugh also why are those kids in so many
public restaurants
have they never seen a law and order
episode
this doesn't end well let's make kids
restrooms [ __ ] trans only kids should
have their own restrooms yeah yeah yeah
by the way like you know like nothing
like
drag queens are the least dangerous
thing in a public restroom yeah you know
like you let your kid walk in barefoot
yeah he stepped on an age needle yeah
yeah you might get [ __ ] with some
hairspray that's about it with a drag
queen
um oh there's a lot here right there's
something about like uh when um there
was like drag queens reading to kids
uh remember and they were like where are
the giant coming to schools reading to
kids it's like oh right in schools
like you know i might have to set up
like catholic schools like
the men in the short dresses no the men
in the long dresses you're fine
you know what i mean just something
about like drag queens in schools yeah
they were they're not dressing like
amish ladies
like priests are fine yeah long robe
fine short dress no
like they're just
i don't know why are priests fine by the
way they don't have a great track record
either that's wild those are the ones
you shouldn't let in the bathroom yeah
i i've have you ever gotten a like a
priest molesting joke to work oh yeah i
got a new one of my special that skills
which one i say uh well i kind of flip
it on jews
basically say uh because i say you know
rabbis [ __ ] a lot of kids too but my
angle is uh you know they do a lesson
priest because i think it's because
jewish kids are really annoying
like like like no one wants a
molestation they're lactose intolerant
no wants to molest a seven-year-old
who's like do i have to get on my knees
they're very achy
[Laughter]
my allergies
my allergies are killing me okay that's
hilarious there's a priest [ __ ] joke
that's hilarious
i've never
never gotten it to work um
never gotten it to work no angle is
hacky and no way
it was it was i mean no no premise
rather i mean bad angle sometimes you
know what it was i think i was i don't
know maybe it's just because people are
so sick of hearing about the sexual
harassment stuff myself included but i
think it was something about like no one
cares when boys get molested and it's
just like when an actress is hugged for
too long we shut down
yeah country like we shut down like if
if an actress is uncomfortable but if a
boy is like [ __ ]
in his church
no there's no martial like no one cares
no one cares no they it's funny like
people it's funny huh when the the the
teacher will [ __ ] a 14 year old boy
galifianakis says that joke like that
kid died from high-fiving you know
that's a great joke but that joke is 15
years old maybe it's the funniest image
of all time just dying from this it's
really the funniest image maybe this is
too jokey but i was like yeah there's no
place for kids that were molested in the
catholic church like to go there's no
charities like best case scenario they
all end up in a.a and all those meetings
take place in a church right right right
rogan had a bit about that oh well he
had a bit about how ladies it sucks when
you go through the raping and all the
the molesting and the harassing but he's
like at least people feel sorry for you
that was his joke yeah if my friend got
blessed by harvey weinstein i'd be like
ah you [ __ ]
you know that's his joke but this is
different there was also um like when
you molest a kid the um
the catholic church will send you to the
vatican
you're like oh that's funny to be
protected so there's something about
like i the belly the beast i don't want
to molest a kid but like
i get a free trip to italy right now i
know travel is cool yeah like i don't
want a [ __ ] kid but like go live in
the vatican it also sucks for the kids
like now i'm going to the super bowl of
molesting that's what they should have
called the show parts unknown
a documentary about the guy that was
molested as the baby the comedian from
boston is boston oh barry criminal barry
cribbens all right
yeah that was like
that was maybe the first time i feel
like i watched something or where i
couldn't make a joke about it hmm i
never saw it i heard it's great
it is it's incredible it's like there's
no way to make a joke
yeah like if you watch it you're like oh
this is just
it was sad it was pretty i i couldn't
even go like man but like he couldn't
even
make a corny joke to cope even after he
got molested though he still had to get
under the spotlight
was a movie about molesting kids all
right that was a stretch but i went that
was a good movie
produced by harvey weinstein i wrote is
that right yeah whoa
best picture pretty sure didn't he
produce spelling is that true
that would be
he was like raped violently when he it's
actually when he was like two
harvey
no
maybe oh that would who are we talking
about no barry chris
yeah yeah yeah the way he like describes
yeah
it makes you so angry yeah that you like
can't function
did it was that wrong did he not produce
all right did you see the whitney
houston documentary i did
the lesbians yeah
yeah yeah how unnerving was that footage
of her on drugs singing
brutal
is that what you guys saw during of me
during the pandemic
this
during the pandemic those were dark
times oh yeah dude can you believe that
happened that's so [ __ ] weird you
know what else is weird i actually was
like
people laugh when i said it but i was
being dead serious i actually think
there's a case to be made
for that time to not count towards our
age i thought the same thing really it's
two years it's like come on we didn't do
anything we didn't live it aged us like
exponentially yeah weirdly it it
shouldn't count i know i'm 39 i'm like i
should be 37. yes like that feels like
it was a
like what is it what uh something's no
i'm not tantamount when it's next to you
like a parallel unit oh yeah completely
was having it was like
yeah it just stopped it all just went
online we just lived online for two
years do you ever see like memories come
up in your phone from like a year ago
and you're like
well a lot of people are getting fired
off of facebook meta whatever because
it's like 10 years ago today and it's
like their halloween photo of them is
pocahontas sure and it's like bringing
out like a lot of people are getting
fired i forget you uploaded justin
trudeau is like delete delete but it
also shows it was a better time because
it was like oh we were free to like you
didn't even think about posting a
pocahontas photo photo you were just
like wow this is fun it's also funny
that you can go as a murderer on
halloween but you can't go as like a
silly like
it's funny right
i'm more scared of the dude in the
screen mask no you can be
viking yeah
you're
a
mike myers
whatever anybody could be oj but you
can't do black foreign that's well i
mean i think there was a big like
as you look back at like the cringy
costumes like you look back at like
paris hilton costumes or like britney
spears costumes and you're like oh
i know but what's a scarier costume a
ghost or a dude who might lose
everything in two years
that's a scarier costume
no it's a weird halloween when you're
scared of the people without masks on
right that's what it was like i mean it
was wild do you dress up on halloween or
no i was
i hold a grudge
and um
i want to say
six years ago when i was living in
studio city i like went all out because
i was like
trying to reconnect to like the child
that didn't get everything
i didn't get what i needed does it mean
i can break the cycle
you know i'm gonna be the halloween
neighbor that i never had i'm gonna be
make the christmas tree that i never had
i'm just gonna like
have it's never too late to have the
childhood you never had
that cost a lot of money to learn
and um and so i dressed up as superwoman
like i'm going to show young girls that
women could be powerful you know i'm
like going to the cvs and walgreens i'm
getting like the kit kats and rolos no
[ __ ] apples no rolos are the most
underrated candy in the game great candy
my number one one one i think they might
be my number one my number number one
always twix is up there but really quick
is up there and kitkat like if you don't
overdo it it's like but rolo is no one
talks about rolo i talk about it a
couple of roles on another level good
name for stephen hawking keep going
we gotta i recently went i was in
baltimore and i got a rolo blizzard whoa
whoa that killed ralphie may yes
he couldn't rollo
um so
uh uh i don't know where i'm going with
this halloween costume childhood comes
to my house i have these amazing things
the kids are like walking you know in
l.a the streets are like on hills you
know
and all the kids you know and so they're
not coming down my cul-de-sac so i was
like running i was like okay i'll just
run towards them and i was like
look guys i'm my house is down here like
do candy like i just
you can't do that yeah you can't chase
kids yeah that's such
like you in a cape like you can't and
none of that i would like look at the
parents and be like
and they were like why do you yeah what
are you doing like none of us want to do
this right you're not allowed to want
this yeah we go on amazon now yeah order
total we're phoning this in like don't
make us come down another street right
we have to do all these houses
like the parents looked at me like
you know and it was like this
heartbreaking moment where i was like oh
okay i'm just gonna leave mister good
bars and mounds out [ __ ] you kids
peanuts out that's the other thing is
that i mean at least in california
they're like peanuts or is there peanuts
oh funny they can't just take candy from
people that's interesting it needs to be
like there's a razor blade now it's a
peanut this is i'm really good that's a
premise last thing i'll say to try to
get you guys out to l.a all right um
well we're never going to move but we'll
be out there i recently had to get a
rabies vaccine i had to get three shots
of uh rabies i have one more strong
pitch so far
because i in the middle of the night let
the dogs out a raccoon like ran up my
leg
and i call animal control because it's
like hanging in my tree and it's like i
don't know if it's sleeping or what and
then they start poking it content
content and
it's like kind of looking at me and like
i do think there's certain instagram
feeds that are gonna
someone's gonna die because they think
dangerous animals are like super snuggly
it's probably happened because of some
japanese feed they follow where like
they sleep with 12 raccoons you're like
oh raccoons are like nice
people are snuggling with tigers and
[ __ ] on instagram and you get dumb
so i call animal control and i'm like i
think i need some help with this raccoon
it's acting weird it might be rabid and
she was like oh no it's fine it's just a
lot of people in la right now they're
testing their cocaine for fentanyl if in
a test positive they flush it down the
toilet so it probably just has some
fentanyl whoa
oh that's a movie premise right there
snake's on a plane yeah raccoons on
fentanyl yes there it is folks check out
the new uh netflix special called the
cancer hooker
[Laughter]
in remission hooker
jokes it's on netflix now give it a
watch uh whitney's podcast good for you
yeah i think
not making a corny title of the special
jokes is perfect it's kind of a good
spot i can't believe it hasn't been done
i know right either i was thinking about
calling it setups and punchlines oh but
i didn't want it to be too i i was gonna
there was a moment i was gonna call it
like actual jokes yeah
that's funny but it's a little
aggressive like mark merritt wouldn't
i just want to be like this isn't a ted
talk i'm not going to like
trick you with comedy and then be
vulnerable
yeah dmitry martin has these are jokes
so you you beat him with the uh economy
of words oh that's right he'll hate you
for that he's not super tight
yeah it's naming a special i wanted to
because i shot it in newark i wanted to
call it live from newark
but i why newark how did you choose yeah
why newer because i kind of feel like
i'm the new work of comedians
you know things that just like how like
you're getting better but i just think
uh the tetanus is cleared off and you've
had cory booker inside you
there we go
um
so look at me i'm editing what i was
thinking i didn't say all the things i
was just saying
it made me feel shame for the rest of
the week um i was in montclair doing a
show there at first i love montclair
yeah beautiful and i was at the
wellmouth theater and i was like i want
to do it here like the show we just did
i just want to you know when you have
like the
i think special should actually
you should never know when it's being
filmed and you're just doing you know
when you'd like do a show and you're
like that was it yes like was anyone
rolling on like what if someone just
came out after the most magical set
everyone was like
just so you know we just shot your
special you're good no you're being
pumped
that'll be great
because you know when you know you're
being filmed it's always just more it's
just weirder and it's just being nice to
be kind of weirdly ambushed on a night
that you weren't thinking about it but
it's hard to capture that magic but um
for sure but then i just kind of was
like you know what like i'm i had to a
run-in or a situation with west virginia
where i made fun of like how half my
family's from west virginia it's kind of
this whole thing and you know there was
this backlash and i was like they wanted
me to apologize and it was kind of like
what is the like what's the actionable
item here like yeah and then they made a
good point they were just like come
perform here make fun of us all you want
but like
help bring business here yeah you know
come to charleston come to west virginia
if you're gonna make fun of us at least
come here and do it to our faces and
help with tourism and stuff and i was
you know that's awesome and i'm gonna
start um choosing the way i do business
in cities that need the you know tourism
or need the economy to be helped out and
like we sit around and joke about newark
all day and make fun of it but no one
actually goes there to do something yeah
you know
there's a gorgeous theater there it's
gorgeous really yeah and it's like no
like carnegie hall doesn't need our yeah
it does it's i mean that's everyone's
dream you know doesn't need a commercial
yeah it's just kind of like why am i
fighting tooth and nail for skirball to
charge me 80 grand where they they're
just i'm annoying to them
want to go to a place that's like
grateful yeah psyched and the audience
was grateful all right i'm going wuhan
next uh special i'll see you there
on the line
i don't get carried away no no
is it whitneycomings.com
the website
who knows anymore
god you never know some people have a
dot jizz or
whatever
see so who knows
but yeah all right thank you so much
this is great
[Music]
check us out my special's out september
1st please watch that
same time tomorrow two more you are an
animal man i have no life
mark where are you going to be on the
road i'm all over where are you going to
plug some days i have a couple days just
left over from oh plug them i have to
have a new hour in three weeks so
i mean cincinnati philadelphia richmond
and charlottesville i'm so sorry
you're going to watch me go what else is
happening
neptune theater uh you got to scroll
sally captain
amazing
all right keep going man comedy
connection oh yeah nice
keep going uh
geez san jose
it's gorgeous i love san jose it's fun
room yeah it's giant toronto it's like
800 seats oh yeah oh is it that big
musical oh wow that's a giant venue i'll
not sell that out we'll do one there
vote theater one of my favorite venues
on the planet oh great joy theater the
wilbur fillmore and phillies zany's all
kinds of fun mark normancomedy.com who
books your dates this really vacillates
back and forth i know from music halls
to like a penguins
we got san jose we got la we've got uh
[ __ ] uh louisville is awesome i think
louisville they still smoke inside
burlington louisville
irvine improv omaha phoenix lexington
new brunswick all over okc
samuel.com shows watch the special same
time tomorrow yeah check it out please
praise all uh thank you whitney thank
you jamie we love you thank you sally
youtube comments y'all good gotham
thanks for having us we'll see you all
in hell
sunday is the day for my next bender
is close
i've had a little too much burping and
norman's talking [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
[Music]
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new orleans
this woman doesn't look like i remember
her and i get down in the same way
we might
be
true
[Music]